[Musique]
elise vendre vendre peinado bonsoir nous
vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne interdite qui s'appelle signe que
review est ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
je suis avocate au barreau de paris
depuis 2013 et je suis présidente d'une
association qui s'appelle anticorps
avocate avocate quoi de pénal droit des
affaires quel type d'avocate je veux non
je défends je défends les salariés
principalement je défends aussi quelques
employeurs je fais du droit commercial
et je fais de la propriété
intellectuelle fut dur à des marques je
fais du droit des marques en dormant
donc vous êtes président d'anticorps
depuis combien de temps ça fait un an
quand vous avez débarqué chez anticorps
depuis quand même temps que vous êtes
chez anticorps pour que vous êtes
intéressé anticorps qu'est ce que vous
faisiez avant
j'ai débarqué anticorps en 2009
ah oui oui on commence par ça alors
anticorps c'est une petite association
qui lutte contre la corruption et pour
l'éthique en politique il ya ces deux 2
axes là c'est une association de
bénévoles on voit on a là deux salariés
on a une juriste et on a une chargée de
communication
et tout le reste c'est des bénévoles
cercle actuellement on à 130 bénévoles
21 au conseil d'administration et le
reste dans des groupes locaux ce conte à
89 groupes locaux et chaque groupe local
est constituée avec un groupe
d'adhérents et ils reçoivent des alertes
de corruption il traite les dossiers ils
demandent des preuves il monte les
dossiers ils écrivent des signalements
qu'ils adressent au procureur de la
république pour voir si le procureur de
la république va faire quelque chose et
s'il ya quelque chose qui bloque ou
alors certains dossiers remontent au
conseil d'administration et dans ce cas
là si le dossier est validé par le
conseil d'administration ont fait des
plaintes
mais en fait ce qui pourrait expliquer
ce que fait anticorps il faut expliquer
un petit peu comment fonctionne le
système pénal français dont en france on
a donc un procureur procureur il enquête
à charge et lorsqu il le pense
nécessaire opportun il saisi un juge
d'instruction pour que le juge
d'instruction lui instruisent à charge
et à décharge manquons un système
binaire entre le parquet et le siège et
on a des caractéristiques qui font que
bat pour la corruption ça bloque déjà on
a ce procureur de la république tous les
procureurs de la république qui ont un
lien hiérarchique avec le garde des
sceaux en gros c'est le garde des sceaux
qui
décide des nominations et qui décide
aussi son administration des évolutions
de carrière donc on a une espèce de
dépendances et puis on a aussi un
principe qui est l'opportunité des
poursuites ce qui veut dire qu'un
procureur peut classer sans suite une
affaire et quand on affaire est classée
sans suite il ya qu' une victime qui
peut aller chercher un juge
d'instruction constitutionnellement
indépendant est en fait pour la plupart
des affaires ça pose pas de problème
parce que il ya très souvent des
victimes
mais en fait en matière de corruption il
peut y avoir des victimes directes c'est
à dire on peut être directement victime
d'un acte de corruption avoir subi un
préjudice avoir pas obtenu un permis de
construire à voir quelqu'un qui a obtenu
un permis de construire alors que en
violation de nos droits ça c'est
possible mais c'est c'est des cas assez
rare pour ce qui est la cause la
corruption globale on estime que les
citoyens sont pas victimes de la
corruption et ça c'est un système qui
est propre à la france parce que en
espagne par exemple il ya les citoyens
sont victimes de la corruption ils
peuvent agir est pareil
tous les systèmes sont pas basés sur
l'opportunité des poursuites ça veut
dire qu en italie par exemple il ya le
principe de l'égalité des poursuites
tous les systèmes non pas un procureur
qui est hiérarchiquement soumis au garde
des sceaux non là on a le combo détroit
ce qui fait que dans certains dossiers
je veux pas dire que les procureurs font
mal leur travail ou sont pas courageux
mais en fait il devrait pas devoir être
courageuse et et dans des dossiers
politico-financiers où il peut y avoir
des pressions et ben eh bien il ya des
associations qui ont commencé à agir
anticor a commencé à agir en justice à
partir de 2009 pour demander à ce que
son statut de victime sont son intérêt à
agir soit reconnue par la justice et
c'est ce qui s'est passé en 2009 c'était
c'était les sondages de l'elysée on a
bataillé 2009 2010 à 2013 pour voir
reconnaître un intérêt à agir
dès 2010 il ya eu une jurisprudence qui
s'appelle la juriste ans des biens mal
acquis ou en fait la justice a reconnu
aux associations qui se battent contre
la corruption qui ont pour objet social
la lutte contre la corruption le droit
d'agir en justice parce qu'elles ont
reconnu probalement qu'il y avait un
besoin
d'intervention de ces associations est
en fait plus plus plus tard en 2013 et
un agrément qui a été créée
et cet agrément
il est donné par le garde des sceaux ce
qui nous pose un peu problème en ce
moment et et nous on l'a obtenu en 2015
on l'a obtenu en 2018 et ça c'est notre
c'est notre outil de lutte en fait
l'instrument qu'on utilise nous pour
intervenir dans les procès pour empêcher
que les affaires soient enterrées parce
qu'elles sont trop
pas être trop dit trop difficile trop
compliqué lll menace des personnes qui
sont trop trop haut placé donc nous
notre boulot c'est quand il ya un
problème d'aller chercher un dossier sur
le bureau du proc et de l'emmener sur le
bureau d'un juge d'instruction qui lui
est constitutionnellement indépendant
c'est à dire qu'il est inamovible
personne ne peut affecter sa carrière et
mais en fait on voit là on ne sait une
espèce de pièces qui ne ment qui
manquait dans le rouage
judiciaires pénales pour pour ces
infractions là pour les infractions sur
lesquelles on bosse et donc l'agrément
qu'on a on concerne certaines
infractions on va reparler de l'agrément
qu'est ce que vous faisiez avant ça
comment vous avez rencontré un petit
corps que vous êtes rentré d'anticorps
ans âge étudié en italie puisque après
le bac je suis parti à florence et j'ai
étudié le droit pendant quatre ans donc
j'ai eu ma ma maîtrise en droit italien
et je suis rentré en france faire une
maîtrise en droit français pour le coup
en deux ans et quand est en fait en
italie moi j'étais pas la vie la vie
étudiante en italie est vachement plus
politisé qu'en france du coup j'ai
découvert tout ce monde assez politisé
que moi je connaissais pas parce que
j'ai une famille qui est très politisée
et donc j'ai découvert ce monde là et
j'ai découvert aussi toutes les frasques
j'ai découvert le monde de berlusconi il
ça c'est mainmise sur les médias ce que
quels étaient les images que les
politiques renvoyer là bas qu'elle était
le taux de corruption l'impact sur la
vie des gens le sur les commentaires le
la confiance des gens envers la
responsable politique même le l'humour
en fait parce que là bas c'est une
question aussi d'humour quand on voit
berlusconi faire n'importe quoi et faire
des blagues et bah en fait c'est
carrément un clown en fait et ça fait
rire les gens alors que alors que c'est
pas drôle et quand je suis rentré en
france je me suis demandé comment
c'était en france parce que j'avais
jamais imaginé que la situation pouvait
être
délétère malsaine comme comme en italie
et du coup je suis tombé sur un article
du monde qui parlait d'anticorps et de
cette intervention dans les procès et
moi j'étais étudiante à la sorbonne g je
me suis dit que c'était un outil de
lutte extraordinaire du coup je les ai
appelés et puis c'était on est encore
une petite association mais à l'époque
c'était vraiment une toute petite
association et ils m'ont invité
emphatiquement invitèrent un bureau de
l'association
voie la moins intégrée tout de suite ils
m'ont dit bah super une étudiante en
droit vient nous aider il y avait une
présidente à l'époque qui était qui
était vraiment un personnage magnifique
et à un moment elle m'a demandé si je
voulais devenir secrétaire général
quelques années plus tard j'ai été
secrétaire général je pense en 22 de
2000 2013 2014
après j'ai fait une pause parce qu'il ya
une crise c'est pas la crème première
crise que subit anticorps et et puis le
président d'après re venu me chercher en
me disant mais vient
revient
d'anticorps du coup je me suis réinvesti
en 2016 et puis j'ai plus arrêter parce
que c'est une asso que je trouve
importantes et
je trouve que ces combats sont
passionnants les les affaires politico
financières sont sont passionnantes mais
aussi tout ce qu'il ya derrière en
termes de réflexion sur la société est
vraiment vraiment passionnant
c'est quoi votre réflexion sur la
société vous et qui l'âge j'ai 34 ans
je dis combien je gagne combien
sur mon activité d'avocat à peu près 40%
montant de temps libre je gagne environ
2000 euros par mois puis
puis quatre ont très peu pour très peu
pour mon activité il ya eu des années où
il ya eu des années où en fait j'ai
peut-être pas eu de loyer j'ai gagné
beaucoup moins parce qu'en fait
je né cessité fait loi ça veut pas dire
j'aime pas mon métier j'adore mon métier
et l'a d'ailleurs mais bon je suis pas
un chef d'entreprise donc en fait j'ai
fait des choix un peu en plus
d'anticorps de prendre des dossiers pas
très cher ou avec plus de résultats donc
là je viens de gagner trois gros procès
donc je pense que je peux arrêter de
travailler
pendant quatre ans pour moi mais ne
rompt jamais été une grande obsédé de
l'argent et j'ai toujours fait avec avec
peu je mens je m'en fous un peu on tique
or vous donne des sous un peu non pas du
tout le budget de fonctionnement
d'anticancer combien par an pour deux
salariés à plein temps bah là on a
vachement grimper en terme de budget
parce qu'on a plus d'adhérents et plus
de donateurs là le budget 2020 c'était
396 1000 euros mais si on vers l'objet
il ya quatre ans je crois que c'était
125 mille euros donc
voilà ça qu'ils sont utilisés pour faire
quoi l'église salarié chez vous il ya un
coût bien
j'espère que je dis pas de bêtises je
crois que notre juriste et à 2500 net et
on a embauché il ya moins d'un an non
une chargée de com qui pour l'instant et
je sais pas je crois que moi j'ai parlé
on est avec elle et que ces 2500 je sais
pas combien ces charges et moi je
suis pas une fanatique de la
comptabilité je me je laisse beaucoup ça
à l'arrière vous avez un
expert-comptable trésorière une
commissaire aux comptes comment ça se
passe les comptes chez vous oui on a une
trésorière on a un expert comptable et
on a même un commissaire aux comptes
puisque quand on dépasse 1 un plafond de
dont on est obligé d'avoir un
commissaire aux comptes moi je m'assure
qu'on respecte toutes les obligations
légales je regarde par rapport à ça mais
après je laisse la trésorière faire son
boulot qu'elle fait très bien de dire
quelle est notre budget qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire voilà est d'ailleurs moi je
suis même
anticor a mis de côté un petit peu
d'argent avec le temps moi je serais pas
du tout pour mettre de côté de l'argent
moi je je crois qu'on a à 120000 euros
de côté
moi je serais pour les dépenses et à
fond prendre prendre des gens qui ont
plus d'expertisé quand on a besoin et
est décortiqué les dossiers y aller je
suis il ya un moment où le conseil
d'administration avait réfléchi à
acheter un bien immobilier pour nos
locaux
je pense qu'on n'est pas là pour là on
n'est pas content et parce que ma
console d'administration qui a il ya
vingt-et-une personnes il y en a une
partie qui sont qui sont nos référents
dans les groupes locaux et puis il ya
des gens
il ya des gens qui sont les militants
qui sont là depuis longtemps
voulez des noms dont 21 ça va faire trop
long dé notre communauté va se charger
de savoir ce qui se passe là bas
revenons revenons aux dossiers politico
financiers pour vous quel est le depuis
ces vingt dernières années pour vous
quel est le dossier politico-financier
le plus énorme ou celui qui vous a fait
le plus beau dire
les mosans 3
c'est difficile parce qu'il ya des
dossiers qui sont passionnants par par
les mécanismes qui montre il ya des
dossiers qui sont
retentissant par les personnes qui sont
mises en cause là on a je pense qu'on a
sont versés par le sang versé par le
sang versé
battleship ah oui on était rentrés dans
le dossier karachi c'est un très très
gros dossier on était rentrés sur le
volet financier
on va des rétrocommissions c'est vrai
qu'il ya du sang versé dans karachi
après nom n'est pas que sur des gros
dossiers en suspens je pense de son
envers ses villas évidemment je pense à
un dossier dans lequel on est entré
parce que
parce que évidemment on peut pas faire
de lien direct mais il ya un pote des
fondations et sinon ouais mais je
préviens déjà d'ores et déjà que tout le
monde est présumé innocent voilà donc le
dossier c'est que c'était un dossier
dans le var où en fait un maire avait
attribué un marché public de transport
scolaire à sa lente reprise qui
dirigeait et il y avait
une personne qui
il y avait des problèmes d'addiction
parmi les parmi des personnes qui va
quitter
chauffeur et il ya eu plusieurs alertes
et lui n'a pas fait son boulot de
contrôle et c'est là que nous on arrive
on dit bah en fait si on peut pas on ne
peut pas être juge et partie on peut pas
contrôler normalement quand on a un
intérêt en termes d'intérêts dans la
sphère et donc bye faute de contrôle
cette situation a perduré il ya eu un
accident très grave puisqu'il ya eu il
ya deux adolescentes qui sont mortes
voilà c'est le sait un petit dossier on
est rentré pour dire que les infractions
à la probité ça mène aussi à sa séquence
des tic en politique
bah
l'éthique en politique
non j'allais vous dire c'est
l'exemplarité c'est 2 mais bon c'est
quoi déjà ne pas commettre il ya la
question de ne pas commettre
d'infraction on travaille énormément sur
l'infraction mais on a aussi plein de
propositions pour pour améliorer pour
améliorer l'éthique en politique pour
améliorer le fonctionnement démocratique
on a des propositions chaque année
chaque année à chaque élection sur le
rôle de l'opposition sur la transparence
de la comptabilité sur l'open data
l'accès des citoyens pour leur permettre
de faire ce qu'ils ont le droit de faire
c'est-à-dire de contrôler tous les
agents publics et puis à iwuy l
exemplarité par rapport à tout tout tout
ce qu'on constate nous en termes de
dysfonctionnements toutes les
infractions à la probité tous les
mélanges
bannu déjà de ne pas laisser un seul
intérêt privé interférer dans l'action
publique dans la prise de décision
publique on a énormément de on a
énormément de dossiers de prise illégale
d'intérêt par exemple
10 exemple je vous en ai donné un avec
avec cette personne qui a confié un
marché à sa propre à sa propre société
il ya des personnes ça peut être du
copinage et des personnes qui embauchent
leurs familles
sans égard sur pour le fait que ce soit
ou pas la meilleure personne et de toute
façon la prise illégale d'intérêt on va
même pas regardé si c'est la bonne
décision on dit juste qu'il doit pas y
avoir d'autres intérêts qui interfèrent
là on arrive au procès guérini ou
anticorps est partie civile on n'y est
pas encore mais on arrive
où on reproche à jean noël guérini
d'avoir
d'avoir facilité la vente d'un terrain
qui pour une société qui finalement
donné des démarches et à son frère son
frère alexandre qui finalement est le
vrai
la vraie personne mise en cause dans ce
procès on a des tonnes en fait de
l'exemple a été jugé donc peut-être
innocent présumé 12 oui il est présumé
innocent on a un dossier dans une ville
aussi où il ya un maire qui est en même
temps
et parce qu'on une boîte de btp est
pareil qui a
qui a permis en tout cas qui a voté
pendant une délibération la vente la
vente d'un terrain avec un projet
immobilier sachant que son entreprise
est sous traitante de certains lots de
ce projet immobilier et qu'en plus cela
la situation et délirante puisqu'il ya
vraiment une perte pour les fonds de
la ville parce que on voit qu'au fur et
à mesure de toutes les autorisations la
vie lui la vie du patrimoine toutes les
délibérations jusqu'au notaire le
le mètre carré a dû passer de 7 700
euros à 400 euros quoi espèce de
déperdition le truc perd de la valeur en
moins d'un an
voilà la question principale c'est c'est
d'arriver à remettre l'intérêt général
au centre de toutes les décisions
publiques voilà c'est quand je vous
écoute vous avez l'air très motivé mais
vous la perception vous avez de la
france avec ses scandales politico
financiers jugés vingt ans plus tard ou
des mises en cous vingt ans plus tard
quelle quelle perception vous avez de
notre pays est ce que c'est un pays qui
se voilent la face concernant sa
corruption qui ne veut pas voir sa
corruption est ce que cette corruption
est toléré parce qu on a vécu grassement
est ce que cette corruption n'est plus
toléré parce que l'on rentre dans une
phase de récession économique
comment vous sentez épaulé par les
magistrats par les forces de police
comme vous êtes perçu par le pouvoir
je crois qu'il ya on a longtemps caché
l'ampleur de la corruption en france et
d'ailleurs les gens s'étonnent encore
nous dire ah bon c'est un pays où il ya
tant que corruption que ça on n'est pas
dans le tiers monde et c'est en fait on
n'est pas très bien classé la france on
n'est pas très bien classé finissez dans
le nord qui dans le classement de
transparancy sur la perception de la
corruption je crois qu'on est 23e 24e
après un pays du golfe d'ailleurs
et donc il ya cette problématique là de
prise de conscience c'est sûr de ce que
c'est que le phénomène de corruption
après nous on a un discours on a ça fait
des années qu'on bosse sur un plaidoyer
où on dise que nous on pense qu'il
faudrait mettre en place pour diminuer
diminuer cet état de fait
améliorer les mécanismes et sur ça on
n'est pas du tout écouter souvent on a
invité à l'assemblée nationale pour pour
parler de nos propositions quand il ya
un texte de loi qui est en préparation
on prépare toujours quelque chose on les
envoie aux députés c'est que c'est quand
même très très rare que ce soit subi des
faits les gens nous disent à arrêter d'y
aller non en fait on continue à y aller
on continue à croire que ça peut être
utile à quelque chose par exemple ça
fait des années qu'on dit qu' il faut
réglementer davantage les marchés
publics marchés publics mais c'est
l'enfer on a plein plein plein de
dossiers de marchés publics de 3,12 dont
way we partout ses surnoms du
département 92 hc par le panier de
crabes ah ouais ouais
mais en fait y en a partout bon c'est
pas du tout
pas du tout propre 92 c'est hallucinant
à quel point il y en a partout et à
chaque fois on parle de dossiers où il
ya
je mens en moyenne 26 millions en jeu
sur un marché public est encore pire
d'ailleurs parce que nous on a on a fait
un signalement sur le dossier du grand
paris par exemple ça c'est un truc
hallucinant dossier du grand paris il ya
eu un rapport d' enquête de la cour des
comptes qui explique qu' il ya
202 100 marchés publics irrégulier c'est
un truc de dingue est là et la cour des
comptes dit qu'il ya eu un dérapage
financier de 13 milliards d'euros donc
la cour des comptes balança et en gros
personne ne réagit personne ne réagit
donc c'est nous qui allons prendre le
rapport de la cour des comptes et écrire
écrire au procureur pour lui dire bah
quand même là faudra va falloir faire
quelque chose
et les procureurs je pense qu'ils ont
entendu la cia des actes d' enquêtes en
cours
mais en fait c'est tellement complexe
mais je pense que la justice a et pas
assez armé sur sa la justice et les
policiers spécialisés puisqu'on a on a
yellow cliff
l'office central de lutte contre la
corruption et les infractions
financières et fiscales et il ya la brd
eux qui la brigade de répression de la
délinquance économique qui bossent
souvent sur ces dossiers là mais ils
sont pas ils sont pas assez armé sur le
sur les 200 marchés publics la en
question vraiment un marché public ça
date un mois de boulot en fait pour
décortiquer tellement c'est ultra
complexes et en mettent donc nous ça
fait des années qu'on dit que les
marchés publics ça va pas qu'il faut les
encadrer et là il vient y avoir la loi
asap et la loi à des règlements
le masque est maintenant le code de la
commande publique et je comprends qu'ils
aient pu
en tout cas entendre la voix des
collectivités qui leur disent mais
arrêtez avec la paperasse nous on veut
faire on veut pas remplir des bulletins
et des dossiers dans tous les sens je
comprends qu'ils aient cette voie d'un
côté et que ce soit nécessaire de
l'écouté mais un temps quand on voit le
grand paris 13 milliards sur nos
finances publiques bas c'est d'où pitot
mais comment on a pu laisser faire ça
comment c'est possible que le grand
paris on arrive avec un truc sans sans
mise en concurrence fin c'est
hallucinant quand même sur un marché de
cette ampleur là en france
et bassa with on laisse les gens faire
des avenants prolonger le bazar
augmenter les prix bas évidemment qu'on
en arrive à des dérapages fenomeno mais
on est dans une dans un contexte de
crise depuis tellement longtemps en fait
c'est pas normal de laisser faire ça et
donc balle arrive la loi à zapper
évidemment toutes les assauts anti
corruption hurle et le truc est passé se
dire que maintenant il ya un plafond qui
est augmentée et en plus de ça les
collectivités peuvent pour des raisons
d'intérêt général décidé de parcourir
ne pas respecter les règles de mise en
concurrence des marchés publics mais pas
le dire la leyre l'intérêt général c'est
le contraire l'intérêt général c'est que
tout soit bien bordé et qu'on contrôler
la dépense financière parce que cet
argent là qu'on compères dans ce genre
de procès sera finalement on en a besoin
pour énormément d'autres choses et on
voit très bien on va très bien en ce
moment
est ce que est ce que ces dépassements
ou est-ce que cet argent de la
corruption de temps en temps ça arrive
dans les caisses des partis politiques
par un gros problème il ya un gros
problème oui sur le financement des
partis politiques oui
la question qu'on se pose en ce moment
et c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on a des
problèmes aussi en ce moment c'est
justement si les marchés publics sur
lesquels on travaille en ce moment ont
pas vocation à
à financer
les élections de l'année prochaine en
partie qu'on est en train de en train
d'y travailler
pour le coup on s'est dit on est
tellement dans des dossiers anciens
on attend tellement de temps ils
sondages de l'elysée on a on a porté
plainte en 2010
à ma connaissance c'est toujours pas
audiencé ou en tout cas c'est pas encore
jugé donc faut pas être trop pressé et
là pour le coup on comme on est mieux
structuré on est on est plus efficace
bon on commence à anticiper commencent à
anticiper et bah oui ça peut faire mal
vous avez subi des pressions parce qu'il
ya des députés ou des politiques qui
nous ont approchés pour
orienter les enquêtes n'ont
pas seulement personne qui nous a jamais
approché pour orienter ce qui est vrai
c'est que l'on soit beaucoup d' alerte
donc en fait on n'est pas toujours au
courant de la motivation des personnes
il ya il ya des gens qui qui dénonce
parfois parce que bah ils ont été
éjectés de deal ça arrive donc c'est la
vengeance ok nous on regarde le dossier
si le dossier intéressant si on a six
l'intéressent association si on se dit
bon il faut il faut qu'on il faut qu'on
intervienne parce que ça va débloquer
quelque chose on parle de plus values
anticorps ici on a une plus value à
intervenir dans ce dossier ben on y va
donc on se préoccupe pas toujours du
fait que ça puisse être une vengeance ou
pas évidemment si on si si le truc est
une instrumentalisation évidente est que
et nous on n'a pas d'intérêt sur le
dossier mal à personne on hésite à les
voir aller voir le procureur la
république vous avez subi des pressions
vous avez des contrôles fiscaux est ce
que anticorps lui des contrôles de ce
type la sq des gens qui bossent avec
vous son fait un push et
alors on en a je pense il ya quelque
chose qui a changé en 2019 je ne crois
pas qu'il ya eu des pressions avant quoi
que je crois que la fondatrice
d'anticorps séverine tessier avait eu
des contrôles fiscaux à l'époque déjà
ce qui s'est passé à partir de 2019
c'est que le vice-président d'anticorps
eric alt
a été l'objet d'une enquête
administrative
c'est à dire une enquête demandée par la
garde des sceaux de l'époque et pendant
un an
pour deux raisons parce que parce que
dans la sphère ferrand il s'est rendu à
l'audition de partie civile anticor
parce que le président ne pouvait pas se
déplacer donc il était vice-président il
s'est rendu à cette audition de partie
civile
est en fait richard ferrand a demandé le
dépaysement du dossier en disant qu'il y
avait un risque de manquer
d'impartialité du tribunal parce que
eric alt et magistrats au tribunal
judiciaire de paris bon il se trouve que
lui il s'occupe du départage aux
prud'hommes donc il s'occupe pas du tout
de pénal
mais ça a justifié le dépaysement de
l'afa richard ferrand est une perte de
temps de six mois au moins et du coup
c'est pour ça que le dossier est
actuellement à lille 12 points et le
deuxième pan c'est une prise de position
d'eric halte sur un autre dossier dans
lequel les anticorps qui est chaud siki
et le détournement des aides agricoles
en corse
on a
on apporte on a porté ce dossier est
quasiment depuis le départ enfin avec
l'aide de beaucoup de lanceurs d'alerté
est en fait le procureur de la
république en corse a fait
une conférence de presse avec la préfète
de corse tous les deux ce qui est
vachement normal
que la justice et l'exécutif de concerts
10 n'y a rien dans ce dossier
dont qu'il a il a critiqué il a critiqué
ce ca de se dire bah c'est pas normal
que le préfet le procureur organise une
conférence de presse ensemble déjà c'est
pas quelque chose qui est normal surtout
qu'en corse en fait ce que nous on met
en cause au delà des détournements par
par les personnes
des aides agricoles c'est un système qui
peut être permis ça a su a toléré à
tolérer ces détournements donc c'est ce
qui est en jeu là dedans et bien
évidemment oui il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui ont qui ont peur après
c'est ca l'olaf
c'est le lave qui est saisie et donc la
chasse national de lutte antifraude le
fils le fils c'est hors pair le laf
et donc voilà donc dans ce dossier c'est
en fait il ya eu un moment un changement
de calcul des aides et avant c'était par
tête de bétail je crois et d'un moment
ils ont dit bon ben on va faire par
terrain et du coup tout d'un coup il ya
des gens qui ont déclaré plein de
terrain terrain de la mairie le terrain
du voisin des terrains qui a été
totalement rocailleux impossible
d'exploiter quoi que ce soit ni de faire
vivre ou du bétail et
et il ya même des gens qui faisaient ça
ils sont en prison
percevait les aides les aides à la pac
man et du coup ben ayad il ya des
personnes qui ont étudié ça représente
quel volume financier
qu'est ce que je vais vous dire une
bêtise je crois que ces 32 millions
je veux bien une vérification c'est
vraiment les chiffres ham
wayne rooney quoi ça fait quoi de trois
périodes sur la plage et revenons
revenons en à nos moutons
[Musique]
votre perception de la france
on est en train de se tirer disait avec
un système judiciaire qui a un budget
qui est ridicule
les policiers les enquêteurs qui ont
abusé ridicule les politiques qui se
font juger dix quinze ans après quand
tout le monde a oublié des pressions à
gauche à droite votre perception c'est
il faut quitter le pays où il faut se
battre enfin vous connaissez ma réponse
sur ça moi ça fait dix ans que je me
bats je crois qu'on est dans un moment
compliqué alors nous on a beaucoup on a
voulu un anticorps faire comprendre aux
citoyens que la corruption était un
problème endémique en france mais en
fait les gens commencent à s'en rendre
compte il n'y a pas de réponse
institutionnelle à ça c'est ça le
problème c'est que finalement
ça va anticor a été créée
après après l'élection de 2002 parce
qu'il y avait un abstentionnisme
délirant et que les gens qui ont créé
l'association ont dit ça il faut que ça
s'arrête
la démocratie représentative peut pas
fonctionner si les soignants font pas
confiance à leurs élus donc il faut
moraliser les pratiques politiques et ça
veut dire aussi bas sanctionner les
personnes qui n'ont pas un comportement
éthique et sens que je vais leur mettre
un petit bracelet électronique qui
passent leurs vacances en corse ça veut
dire quoi c'est quand on prend deux ans
avec sursis
on peut se balader avec un petit
bracelet si un peu plus ou d'un range la
peine parce qu'on comprend c'est quoi il
faut il faut faire quoi quand quand
est-ce qu'il faut avoir des peines
exemplaires façon chine ou corée du nord
sur les gens qui tapent dans la caisse
où il faut continuer gentiment et les
met fleury mérogis dans des
cellules de luxe
ah bah non je suis pas d'accord pour les
cellules de luxe on se bat pour
l'égalité devant la loi donc en fait moi
ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'on prenne
toutes les condamnations à des d
infraction quelle qu'elle soit qui sont
punissables de cinq ans de prison et
qu'on regarde si si c'est le cas aussi
pour dans ces cas là j'ai été j'ai été
invité sur les plateaux télé après la
condamnation de monsieur sarkozy mais
c'était un truc incroyable tout le monde
sur les plateaux télé 10ème et une
condamnation d'une sévérité phénoménal
et il a été il est de nouveau présumé
innocent mais le tribunal en première
instance l'a reconnu coupable de deux
infractions qui sont punissables de cinq
ans de prison chacune et il a pris un an
ferme deux ans avec sursis j'aimerais
bien voir si si on prend les autres
infraction punissable de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement on a en moyenne sur la
population des condamnations un an ferme
et deux ans de sursis j'aimerais bien
qu'on regarde ça la question c'est
l'égalité devant la loi le combat
d'anticorps c'est c'est la fin de
l'impunité
la fin de l'impunité est ce que vous
avez peur comme en italie que par
exemple ceux qui trafiquent avec le
béton
vous attrapez un jour vous coule dans le
est-ce que vous avez été suivi ce que
tout ça non je
n'en je dis ça à moi non moi non on a
des militants qui ont qui ont été
plus ou bousculer on a on a des
personnes qui qui ont reçu des menaces
qui ont reçu
du type le bouquin avec écrit traître
avec le couteau avec du sang dessus et
on a une militante dont dont le fils a
été enlevé très brièvement
elle pense qu'il voulait pas l'enlever
qui voulait savoir où elle habitait donc
son gamin sortait de l'école ayant une
voiture qui lui a dit mais c'est un
moment qui m'a demandé de te ramener de
te ramener à la maison je la connais
elle s'appelle comme ça elle est grande
elle est brune je vais être accompagnée
chez toi donne moi ton adresse et le
gamin à 11 ans il a donné l'adresse d'un
copain et
et mais bon elle a déménagé quand un
truc comme ça vous arrive on déménage
c'est normal donc voila moi je pense que
finalement de ce genre de menaces on est
plus susceptible quand on est au bureau
d'anticorps on est officiellement les
dirigeants d'anticorps on est peut-être
peu susceptible de les subir
mais en revanche parfois sur le terrain
c'est d'une violence inouïe ce qui se
passe
sreg l'ancienne c'est ça
bah oui il ya encore des espèces de
baronnies dans ce pays où quand on
attaque quelqu'un finalement on se fait
on se prend une vague de violence et
c'est ce qu'on se prend généralement
anti-chars en ce moment mais
nous on le voit de façon dont on nous
reproche parfois de porter plainte
contre intel contre intel si on porte
plainte contre quelqu'un qui qui fait
partie de telle famille politique
beaumont à tous toutes les personnes qui
tous leurs militants qui nous reprochent
d'avoir fait ça d'être politisé si on
porte plainte contre une personne d'un
autre parti politique c'est la même
chose c'est la vague aussi contre nous
il ya des réactions qui sont qui sont
assez violente viscérale pour pour
protéger des personnes ont des intérêts
sur internet le fondateur eric halphen a
ouvertement soutenu maquereau en 2017
comment agir en toute indépendance et ne
pas être accusé de politisation dans ces
conditions
erik alfheim ça fait longtemps qu'il est
qu'il est plus actif qu'il est plus
actif en du corps
moi je trouve ça
assez bien en fait l'idée d'anticorps
c'est en tout cas jusqu'à présent est
temps que l'assemblée générale décidera
pas autrement l'idée d'anticorps sais
c'est pas d'être apolitique c'est des
trans partisan notre idée c'est que
anticor a été créée par des élus après
on
il ya eu la création d'une autre
association qui s'appelle les amis
d'anticorps après ils ont fusionné donc
il ya eu associations d'élus et de
citoyens contre la corruption
et donc nous on est parfaitement à
l'aise avec ça de dire que les gens à
l'intérieur d'anticorps ils ont le droit
d'être les partis politiques tant mieux
s'il ya une diversité d'ailleurs et
c'est le cas il ya une il ya une grande
diversité
parmi nos plus gros gl il ya des gens
qui sont de se le dise à des groupes
locaux mais les groupes dans les
départements parmi nos plus gros
responsable dans les départements il ya
des il ya des personnes qui sont gauche
qui sont de droite il ya tout et sur
internet comment anticorps se protègent
de la corruption ou sein de leur service
un service
la corruption ben nous on a plein de on
a plein de règles en fait on a des
statuts on a une charte organisationnel
on a tous les dirigeants tous les
dirigeants charte shirt c'est un peu
comme la charte de munich maxime charte
de munich
c'est une espèce de chars tous les
journalistes piétine dessus il utilise
comme papier toilette ah mais non non
non on fait pas ça encore chouette parce
que si si si c'est vrai qu'une chose ah
bah oui
les gens là là je pense pas enfin on a
plein de système mais en gros on a donc
on a tous nos responsables associatifs
qui remplissent une déclaration
d'intérêts qui disent quel métier ils
font ou est-ce qu'il est nous aussi
gagnent leur argent ils disent ils ont
des responsabilités
administratif un mandat électoral ils
sont impliqués dans un parti politique
ce qui nous permet à nous s'il ya un
problème de vérifier que il
ils sont bien mis en déport comme ils
doivent le faire s'ils ont un intérêt
personnel dans un dossier après on a des
obligations de retrait a raison quand il
ya des gens qui veulent
soutenir un candidat ou alors eux-mêmes
être candidat on leur demande de se
mettre en retrait il communique plus
pour anticorps ils prennent plus de
dossiers ils font plus rien
et et puis on a un comité d'éthique qui
est notre organe un peu
disciplinaire interne qui peut être
saisie par n'importe quel adhérents
n'importe quel adhérents d'anticorps
peut dire bah regarder cela il prend des
dossiers pour anticorps mais en fait ce
dossier là il est intéressé parce qu'il
déteste le maire ou parce qu'il veut se
présenter tout le monde sait très bien
que du coup le comité d'éthique qui est
composée d'adhérents
bah traite les dossiers et puis donne un
avis au conseil d'administration et puis
le conseil d'administration prend des
décisions si il faut en prendre de duras
du rappel à l'ordre à l'exclusion
ou de questure internet comme anticorps
choisissez pour roy à défendre ou
attaquer
alors les proies à défendre on défend
pas vraiment de personnes on remet des
prix éthiques chaque année donc on a
deux événements principaux ont fait une
université et une remise de prix éthique
et de casseroles comment est-ce qu'on
l'ait choisi banc
on garde dans l'année écoulée en gros
qui a changé la donne qui a eu un impact
dans nos combats
on en donne généralement à des si on
peut s'il ya encore des lanceurs
dallaire dans ce pays malgré le fait que
c'est vraiment dur de l'être on en donne
à des lanceurs d alerte on annonce la
loi sapin c'est ça oui moi il ya une
directive qui en cours de transposition
en droit français mais on n'en parlerait
si vous voulez on en donne à des
journalistes on en donne à des élus avec
grand plaisir quand on peut et on en
donne des écrivains à des chercheurs son
ami ahmad des prix pour des thèses aussi
parce que ça participe du combat
et on donne des casseroles à des
personnes alors pour lesquels on n'a pas
contre lesquelles on n'a pas porté
plainte
c'est une règle mais des personnes qui
ont se sont illustrés
sont illustrés parfois par des
comportements qui sont pas forcément
qualifiable pénalement mais qui
franchement jour
là on a eu
alors c'était en
c'était en 2020 on a remis des
casseroles au couple ferrand rien à voir
avec richard ferrand mais c'est un coup
pour en fait ils ont été chacun
condamnés je crois pour prise illégale
d'intérêts l'un après l'autre et puis du
coup l'autre prenez la mairie quand
laurent quentin était inéligible c'est
l'autre personne dans le couple qui
prenait la mairie ils ont fait ça
pendant un moment jusqu'à ce qu'il
décide de se présenter l'un contre
l'autre voilà ça nous a fait là dans ces
cas là c'est ce qu'ils votent c'est un
peu comme à levallois-perret
cesser ceux qui votent pour le maire qui
sont responsables ah bah on peut dire
que les citoyens sont complices oui dans
une certaine mesure c'est pas trés
subvention de vote de la subornation de
vote oui c'est bien voter pour eux c'est
ira bien je vais vous faire des beaux
trottoirs sans caca de chien bon je
crois que les gens ont du mal à voir que
que la corruption c'est aussi sous leur
nez et puis bah il ya probablement plein
de gens qui
qui se disent non mais mon père sava
maire il a fait ça mon fer mer il fait
des trucs bien ça c'est les fameuses
galettes balkany c'est du clientélisme
c'est
du clientélisme puis c'est sûrement
aussi du déni de pas vouloir voir que
pas vouloir voir les effets délétères de
politique locale mais c'est ce qu'on
n'arrête pas de dire aux personnes là on
a fait un espèce de guide pour et ses
dires au citoyen si ça vous intéresse de
voter pour quelqu'un qui qui est un
comportement éthique aller vérifier ça
ça et ça et donc voilà on est dit
ouvrir les yeux et puis il faut qu'il
faut se dire que c'est pas c'est pas la
galette de fin d'année qui va compenser
l'organisation de la collectivité les
services genre jean oui merci fixes
comme les cartes de voeux aussi ça c'est
marrant c'est petit mais je regarde les
époques pour les vieux et tout le temps
obligé will objets cartes de voeux les
piles etc ou demain je pense les places
en crèche moi ça m'énerve quand je vois
des systèmes où finalement les gens sont
contents parce que ils obtiennent des
marchés plus des marchés publics des
services publics qui devraient avoir
mais du coup le fait d'octroyer un
quelque chose qui est des relève du
service public devient une faveur elle
est donc créé un sentiment de
reconnaissance et sa sa maman furax en
fait parce que avec un fonctionnement
normal des institutions des
collectivités avec surtout tout cet
argent de la corruption ça a quand même
été chiffré à 120 milliards d'euros par
an le coût de la corruption avec tout
cet argent qu'on réintègre
c'est combien le pib français je sais
pas
c'est tout cet argent qu'on ne rien
j'écoute pas bon c'est
facile d'aller retrouver cet argent mais
mais en tout cas une grosse partie oui
on notamment en entrant les marchés
publics et plein d'autres choses qu'on
pourrait qu'on pourrait éviter de
dépenser aurait intégré dans la finance
publique et espérer avoir un
fonctionnement un meilleur
fonctionnement des services publics
alors question d'exo 7 quelle est la
différence entre corruption et lobbying
est ce que par exemple admettons que je
souhaite un grand chirurgien qui est
pratique les greffes de cheveux et que
me propose d'aller voyager aux maldives
tous frais payés pour aller par les deux
minutes de
la racine capillaire celle au chouf
et que je rentre et que derrière comme
j'ai vu que le démonstrateur avec la
lotion spécial cheveux je prescris cette
lotion spécial cheveux c'est quoi c'est
de la corruption c'est pas de la
corruption fait d'éteindre un statut en
fait ce serait plus facile si si on
prenait l'exemple par les experts de la
haute autorité de santé parce que ils
sont en charge d'une mission de service
public ça qui change en fait il ya plein
d infractions sur lesquelles on bosse on
qu'on ne peut reprocher cas des
personnes qui sont en charge d'une
mission de service public si vous prenez
des experts de la haute autorité de
santé par exemple on leur demande de ne
pas avoir de liens d'intérêts venant
interférer avec les travaux qui leur
sont demandés de faire dans l'intérêt
général dans l'intérêt des patients et
là on a en a porté plainte par exemple
contre
contre six experts de la haute autorité
de santé
qui avait bossé
sur des questions de
hypercholestérolémie
et les statines et qu'ils avaient et qui
avait pas sur neuf il y en avait six
voire sept nains a laissé un de côté et
il y en a en tout cas m6 qui avaient des
liens avec
des liens financiers avec des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
qui commercialisait des statines
délire direct financier c'est ça le
voyage aux maldives
c'est considéré comme un des financiers
ou pas ah bah oui s'ils veulent le
voyage et payé on m'a dit vincent car
les voyages les cadeaux les déjeuners on
prend tout en compte mais même si mon
travail est enfin là c'est du travail
c'est une participation à un événement
de façon si vous soit vous êtes rémunéré
pour faire une demi-heure de speech soit
vous n'êtes pas rémunérés pour faire une
dernière de ce pitch mais tout le voyage
vous est offert et vous est resté dix
jours c'est clairement un avantage
financier peut-être qu'il n'apparaît pas
comme ça donc il est peut-être moins
faciles à détecter
mais les les avantages financiers comme
les rémunérations pour les conventions
tout ça au moins on à la base
transparence santé qui nous permet
d'aller vérifier mais ce qui est dingue
c'est que nous on va vérifier et enfin
neuf qui ça c'est pas nous c'est le
formindep qu' une super à ceux qui
bossent sur sa sur les conflits
d'intérêts
dans le monde médical
nous en gros on va vérifier les
informations et la haute autorité de
santé ne le fait pas et ça c'est assez
problématique quand même enfin
maintenant je pense qu elle le fait elle
a compris je vous ai coupés sur les
statines
banon sur les statines je terminais non
on a porté plainte pour prise illégale
d'intérêts donc maintenant ça va être à
la justice de dire si
si les paiements
bah si les payements constitue un
intérêt qui est interdit par la loi et
la question que vous me posez c'est est
corruption et lobbying en fait les
opérations de lobbying ça c'est un truc
ça fait des années qu'on dit qu'il faut
encadrer lobbying et encore moi je suis
mesuré mais il ya beaucoup de personnes
dans l'assaut qui pensent qu'il faut
l'interdire
je pense que si on l'interdît se fera
dans d'autres sphères et que finalement
il vaut mieux l'encadrer
et on a une on a une situation où il ya
des plein de boîtes qui dépensent une
thune monstrueuse
passé plusieurs dizaines de millions
d'euros parfois j'en faudrait voir alors
là aussi un registre
des représentants d'intérêts etc ces
montants sont déclarés donc si vous
allez voir ce que dépense totale chaque
année en opération d' influence tir bas
franchement ça ne peut que être rentable
pour dépenser autant d'argent c'est
forcément rentable après ce que c'est
mal de chercher en tant qu'entreprise a
influencé la décision publique vieira en
fait c'est des intérêts et c'est aussi
compréhensible que défendre leurs
intérêts le problème c'est que c'est
fait dans l'opacité sont des rendez vous
personne ne sait quels rapports sont
remis il ya aucune contradiction par
rapport à aux rapports qui sont remis
les sujets sont plus en plus complexes à
l'assemblée demande à nos députés
de voter sur des trucs ultra complexes
auxquels ils ont pas ils ont pas la
balle expertise c'est normal sur tous
les sujets avec un calendrier
parlementaire quand même qui secoue pas
mal et à côté de ça vous mettez des
lobbyistes qui arrivent avec des
rapports super parfait et avec à la fin
une petite conclusion de six pages et un
amendement clé en main donc tout
souhaité organiser pour que cette
influence fonctionne en fait et
donc nous serons ce qu'on dit c'est que
il faut encadrer il faut encadrer sa
faut arrêter les rendez-vous dans les
bureaux ça suffit la décision publique
elle peut pas elle peut pas être un pas
être influencée dans l'ombre c'est pas
possible ce qu'on aimerait bien même ces
qui est carrément une plate forme qui
soit l'unique intermédiaire de
communication entre les lobbystes et les
décideurs publics dire si vous avez
quelque chose à dire un élu de la nation
bas vous allez écrire un message il va
être publié vous avez un rapport à
donner ben il va être aussi accessibles
au public et s'il ya des scientifiques
s'il ya des associations qui ont elles
ronzon jamais les mêmes moyens mais au
moins elles pourront peut-être apporter
un peu de contradiction et dire bah non
en fait il ya d'autres intérêts parce
que oui parce qu'un élu si on bat si on
lui présente que certains intérêts ils
se trompaient pas forcément compte qu'il
y aura d'autres intérêts moi c'est moi
je vais gérer même varin espèce de de
tribunal de l'intérêt général de dire
peut-être qu'on peut défendre nos points
de vue aussi mais c'est peut-être mon
expérience du monde judiciaire
quand macro et 10 à 60 millions de
procureur c'est maintenant qu'elles
disent inquiets ce qu'ils avaient dit ça
est-ce que c'est macron je sais plus qui
a dit ça
si si si on vous dit à 60 millions
procure un camp comme on entend les
politiques pesté parce qu il ya trop de
transparence vous rendez pas quand c'est
pas bien ça vous fait quoi
bon allez chante tournée je me dis bon
peut-être quoi il faut plus de pédagogie
il faut leur expliquer en fait de la
pédagogie avec
les flux de bûcheron non non mais non
mais on n'est pas toujours on n'est pas
toujours violent dont c'est aussi
expliquer les choses on peut aller voir
les élus allaient voir les élus et leur
expliquer que ben le système sur lequel
repose leur mandat va pas tenir si les
citoyens n'ont pas confiance en eux et
que et puis que que déjà pour ce qui est
pour ce qui est financier basse et c'est
quand même normal il faut arrêter de
confondre sa poche gauche c'est sa poche
droite il ya quelque chose qui relève de
l'argent public et ilja laurs lors la
leurs salaires leurs indemnités et qu'
ils ont pas intérêt à confondre les deux
mais ça je crois qu'avec avec certaines
affaires ça commence à être compris quoi
que si je vous fais une proposition par
contre par exemple
on doit être à prendre la main dans le
pot de confiture
il est déclaré coupable
on est en prison est-ce qu'il faut tout
lui prendre on lui prend tout et quand
il sort de prison où il laisse avec un
smic n'aime pas qu'on lui met le rsa
ont fait quelques exemples banon ne
retranche un ou deux il ameute se calme
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on reprenne notre
petite tradition française d'aller les
chercher
il faut il faut que la peine soit
dissuasive
après je pensais pas des opinions josie
ho millions
je crois pas que l'humiliation génère
quoi que ce soit bon oui ce poste l'un
des politico je crois que personne
n'aime ça je pense pas que ça génère
quelque chose de vertueux de toutes
façons de
d'humilier les gens dont je crois qu'il
faut il faut que les autres se disent
que ce système finalement il
est bancal maintenant que ça va plus
passer que ils vont avoir vraiment des
conséquences lourdes
probablement ça veut dire passer par
effectivement une peine de prison même
si je suis pas pas une fanatique de
prison mais nous ce qu'on dit aussi que
c'est que il faut des peines
exemplaires oui si vous voulez vous en
tout cas normal comparable à ce que une
personne qui est reconnu coupable pour
un deux délits de cinq ans prendrait
mais que peut être aussi il faut
réfléchir à l'inégibilité et c'est ce
que moi j'ai dit dans le procès sarkozy
en fait parce que apparemment le parc
national financier à part requis une
peine d'inégibilité mais en fait si on
réfléchit pourquoi est ce qu'on met les
gens en prison on les met en prison
parce qu'on estime qu'ils sont dangereux
pour la société dangereux physiquement
et d'un dîner gibily tcl à peine pour
les personnes qui sont dangereuses pour
la démocratie
on les écarte de la vie publique quand
son parce que c'est des hypnotiseurs
l'hypnotise avec notre pognon il soluble
et on les laisse comme ça et c'est pas
bien faut vraiment les
jbe l'itc dissuaderait ben ça ça les
empêche les empêche de revenir dans la
vie publique c'est comme si on expulse
est quelqu'un de la vie de la cité on
dit qu'ils sont ils sont indignes de
détenir un mandat de d'être
fonctionnaires mais de façon pour être
fonctionnaire faut un casier judiciaire
vierge ce qui n'est pas le cas pour les
élus ce qui éclaire un peu bizarre on a
interdit à tous les fonctionnaires
d'avoir la moindre condamnation mais
mais on est toujours dans un système où
les élus peuvent être
et lui même si l'on est déjà été
condamné et même si on a déjà été
condamné pour corruption ou à d'autres
parce que pour briguer certains postes
en politique il faut en avoir mangé il
faut faire partie de de la bonne cantine
il faut
donner un peu des miettes à certains
pour pouvoir grimper démarche c'est ça
ouais moi je connais pas vraiment les
partis politiques ce que je vois c'est
qu'il ya des ouais il ya des réseaux il
ya des réseaux il ya des gens qui se
tiennent qui se rendent des services il
probablement
qu'ils en savent beaucoup ça m'a fait
marrer quand un moment il ya trois
bouquins qui sont sortis avec des pôles
deux politiciens et alexandre bédat là
qu'ils disaient ce qu'ils ne veulent pas
que je dise ce que je dirais un jour ça
impressionne qui ils sont tous ils ont
tous gros sur la patate et qu'ils ont
ils ont plein de choses plein de choses
à raconter les autres sur les autres et
ça les autres
est ce que est ce que vous êtes
on m'a souvent posé la question en
termes de campion puis on l'a vu
d'ailleurs l'actualité récemment avec le
gang des francs maçons au tueur est ce
que les réseaux francs-maçons chez
pramac
le polo question est-ce que vous dont
vous affaires politico financières
on voit certains réseaux de l'ombre
sortir alors je dis par exemple les
franc mac mais ça peut être d'autres
réseaux
non on a on a beaucoup de personnes qui
nous envoie des alertes et qui nous
disent a jusqu'à présent moi j'ai pas vu
de preuves et pour rester sain d'esprit
on ne fonctionne que sur des preuves
question internet pourquoi la cour des
comptes et met un rapport si on ne tient
pas compte de ceux qui dit dedans en
gros pourquoi on paye la cour des
comptes pour faire un rapport pour vous
prévenir et ensuite on s'en va c'est la
question qu'on se pose c'est pour ça
qu'on est à peu près les seuls à lire
les rapports de la cour des comptes
et et puis pourquoi en fait il ya ça on
ne prend pas en compte et puis il ya
tout un truc qui dysfonctionnent parce
que on a aussi en france l'article 40 du
code de procédure pénale qui est censé
obliger
tous les fonctionnaires tous les agents
publics a dénoncé un crime ou un délit
sauf que sa personne le fait en fait il
n'y a pas de sanction
mais bon on est quand même un peu là-bas
en fait la cour des comptes elle elle
devrait peut-être elle même saisir le
procureur de la république c'est normal
c'est pas normal que personne ne
réagisse et qu'il faille qu'une
association comme anticorps
10 lots on en train de parler de 13
milliards là pendant c'est ce qu'on fait
mais pourquoi on les paye attention faut
vraiment continuer à les payer parce
qu'ils font ils font un boulot
extraordinaire
thierry breton vous en pensez quoi
bon
[Musique]
on a craint on a croisé dans un dossier
c'était marrant cette succession de
proposition pour les commissaires
commissaire européen parce que
finalement il ya eu sylvie goulard
sylvie goulard baume révélations
quelques elle elle est rémunérée par un
think tank en même temps qu'elle est qu
elle est élue elle a été a été députée
européenne je crois on a porté plainte
contre sylvie goulard
et le second choix ça a été thierry
breton et thierry breton était le patron
d'atos et atos est une société
en nous on a on a porté plainte contre
des marchés publics de radars
automatiques en fait qui ont été
attribués à à tous donc c'était bon ben
on a porté plainte contre la première
est le second c'est déjà fait on s'est
un peu normand demandé mais bon c'est de
façon on verra ce que dit la justice est
évidemment encore une fois ils sont
présumés innocents et on s'est demandé
si
si si dans le monde politique il n'y
avait pas d'autre candidat ces six
étaient les seules personnes sur la
liste
en question internet d'après elle la loi
de moralisation de la vie politique
publique pardon je recommence d'après la
loi de moralisation de la vie publique
at elle eu un impact
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce que
ça on verra après donc la loi la loi de
moralisation de la vie publique
[Musique]
moi je pense qu'à
80% c'était de la bonne poudre de
perlimpinpin
la poudre de perlimpinpin
de la poudre un peu comme ça non j'ai
pas dit ça il ya un truc qui a été bien
qui a avancé c'est la suppression de
certains avantages
complètement complètement anachronique
dont celle hier et femmes qui a été
supprimée par cette loi sauf que ça a
été remplacé par l'est la
mfc non ça
une autre indemnité qui en gros
équivalente et on est toujours dans une
situation où finalement pour un certain
montant
les les parlementaires n'ont pas à
justifier de ce qu'ils font de l'argent
public donc finalement on a supprimé un
système pour en insérer un autre et
conserver ce qui pose problème c'est à
dire que en fait un parlementaire il
devrait être dans la même situation que
des gens en entreprise quand il a des
frais promis il balance ses factures
donc un peu comme dans les pays
nordiques dont oui bah là bas ya une
culture
de ma peine qui a été viré parce que ou
cab a posé sa démission parce qu elle
s'était fait rembourser que je sais de
chocolat comme ça oui oui là-bas là-bas
ils ont la jurisprudence balladur fois
sans
en france dont on regarde un peu comme
des pays sous développés dont
non alors mis peuple en tant que peuple
français
nous les les pros régicide les
inventeurs du régicide je dirais les
pays nordiques vous avez déjà voyagé un
peu en finlande en suède au danemark et
en norvège et en ciel ouais ils nous
regardent un petit peu comme si on était
des singes dans
oui mais en même temps je ça franchement
limité comme comme un rêve comme
jugement si c'est le cas parce qu'on n'a
pas du tout les mêmes réalités donc
c'est facile de faire la comparaison
j'ai eu des reportages où il disait ou à
l'école en suède ou en norvège c'est
fantastique avec 15 élèves par classe
permis en fait non on n'a pas on n'a pas
les mêmes réalités c'est pas la peine de
comparer ce qui n'est pas comparable est
basé sur le taux de suicide au site web
oui oui bah oui si on regarde même et
financement j'ai cru comprendre que la
norvège investissait
énormément dans des financements ultra
bizarre ils ont pour pendre un de
financements ultra bizarre un peu plus
loin et
voilà je vais prendre une autre question
internet
ouais t'as encore fait une faute
d'orthographe corruption à tous non
est-ce que redick or soutient julian
assange
pourquoi
parce que c'est parce que c'est un
lanceur d alerte parce qu'il a il a
révélé des informations qui
auraient dû permis aurait dû permettre
un sursaut un sursaut démocratique sur
des systèmes de surveillance
généralisée et que c'est parce qu'il a
révélé sa queue qu'il est poursuivi
l'optimisation fiscale celtique
non
non c'est pas pratique c'est légal
l'eagle ca légal
passer ces permis par la loi
l'optimisation fiscale c'est c'est
différent donc c'est pas de la fraude
c'est à dire que quelqu'un qui fait de
l'optimisation fiscale peut être en
règle avec toutes les législations
fiscales
mais il va mettre son argent ses actifs
dans des pays où on paye moins d'impôts
et c'est
aujourd'hui bas parmi par l'union
européenne ce n'est facilité en fait
part
par l'union européenne puisqu'il ne
diffère pas
autant c'est une question sur laquelle
il faudrait l'unanimité donc je sais pas
quand est ce qu'ils ont ils vont réussir
à légiférer pour autant qu'il ait une
volonté politique
majoritaire en tout cas elle sera
arrêtée par cette règle de l'unanimité
qui est un peu spécial
et puis à plein de choses qui sont mis
en place et qui sont bas qui sont
tolérés il ya
il ya les prix de transfert qui sont
fixées par les entreprises il ya les
remontées de royalties aux deux pays
ouais les remontées de dividendes
les remontées de royalties pour les
utilisations des marques dont il ya ya
ya pléthore de montage dans l'union
européenne le gold
oui c'est légal c'est très patriote
bah c'est pas très patriote non parce
qu'on a besoin d'argent dans le pays ou
ont normalement quand on a une activité
économique dans un pays on devrait
participer aux routes aux écoles et aux
hôpitaux tout cas c'est ce qu'ont
c'est ce qu'on mange normalement un
bon citoyen
pourquoi les gens font ça c'est pour
sert plus de blé c'est parce que ils en
ont marre qu'il ya une espèce de
ribambelle de politiques qui se gave
dans le pot de confiture ils en ont
marre de voir des infirmières pays à
1500 euros il décide voilà de faire
sécession
ou ou où ils ont décidé de remettre
aussi plein les poches bah y'a juste pas
y apprend plein de clés de de réponse la
dent oui c'est probablement pour payer
le moins d'impôt possible alors pourquoi
pour un particulier on pourrait dire que
c'est effectivement pour pour avoir plus
d'argent
les sociétés je pense que avec
avec la réalité des sociétés des grosses
sociétés aujourd'hui en fait je suis
même pas sûre que
que dans le cadre appartement au sénégal
l'option soit possible en fait je pense
pas que le mec qui est actionnaire d'une
boîte qui dit
non je veux construire installe en
france
parce que c'est plus patriote va avoir
beaucoup de soutien je pense qu'il va
faire un gros bide parce qu on est dans
un monde où
les le monde de l'entreprise s'est
énormément financiarisé que ce qui
importe c'est les chiffres sur le bilan
de fin d'année
qu'est ce que vous pensez du boycott
c'est une arme qui me plaît énormément
elle passe par
elle passe par une volonté des citoyens
tellement forte que qui pisse abandonné
des choses qu'ils aiment qui veut partir
leur vie et c'est pas forcément facile
il ya une asso qui s'appelle haye
buycott pour le coup
qui est qui est vachement bien interdit
le boycott en france ou d'appeler au
boycott
ben non je crois pas
si c'est interdit je suis bon c'est pas
ma spécialité je crois pas je pense
qu'il ya des assauts qui le font en
disant
boycott jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à ce que
cette société a amélioré ses systèmes
non c'est plutôt vachement bien parce
que finalement
impression que les citoyens ont
une possibilité d'action qui est qui est
assez limité et je trouve que le pouvoir
d'achat est une arme qui a complètement
sous-estimé on devrait complète des
cartes bleues ouais commencer la chanson
de 16 tous parlent de carte bleue
question internet est ce que dans vos
projets vous êtes en train d'étudier le
projet lyon turin à 30 milliards qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
moi je le connais mal ce dossier mais
c'est un dossier qui a été il faudrait
poser la question denis robert puisqu'il
a un parti de porter ce dossier et puis
surtout un nom à nos geyser curieux mais
là plus anciens militants qui s'appelle
raymond avrillier qui ont tous les deux
porté ce dossier j'irai pas grand chose
vraiment je le connais pas très bien
parce qu'on n'est pas partie civile dans
ce dossier et que par ailleurs on à 115
dossiers en cours donc
pas tout connaître
non c'est une régression internet
qu'en est il de la corruption chez les
journalistes
alors est ce que les ménages des
journalistes est considéré comme de la
corruption est ce que les ménages où
elle aimait d'âge quand ils vont faire
le monsieur loyal pour arriver des
petites soirées
n'ai jamais vu ça c'est absolument divin
c'est magnifique je n'ai jamais vu ça ça
c'est caviar c'est le petit ferrero
rocher à la soirée de l'ambassadeur
est ce qu'est la corruption chez les
journalistes pas peut-être il peut y en
avoir partout la corruption moi j'ai
rien à voir chez les juges en fait il ya
des juges il ya des personnes
il ya des personnes procureur aussi non
oui oui mais partout en fait je prends
je pense pas qu'il ya un seul métier
qu'ils soient protégés de la corruption
il ya des personnes qui dysfonctionnent
après moi ce que je demande c'est qu'on
ce que je conseille ce que j'aimerais
c'est qu'on jette pas l'opprobre sur un
métier parce qu'il ya quelques personnes
qui dysfonctionne c'est tout mais oui à
bram
plein de journalistes qui sanctionne moi
je skie me ce qui me chagrine dans les
médias actuellement c'est plutôt que
la contradiction l'espace de liberté
d'expression des opinions me semble de
plus en plus réduits quoi il y en a un
peu marre des plateaux télé où on dit
que
dit pauvre sarkozy la communauté veut
faire remonter l'information à qui veut
dit l'appel au boycott est désormais
interdite en france depuis quand on
recherchera ils vont nous trouver sa
voie mais sait que c'est dangereux
on va parler un petit peu d'évasion
fiscale et d'optimisation fiscale donc
l'optimisation fiscale c'est légal c'est
ça et l'évasion fiscale c'est interdit
l'avion fiscal oui c'est la prod c'est
la fraude fiscale qui est interdite
après elle peut en fait vous pouvez
avoir un montage d'optimisation fiscale
qui est requalifiée en fraude fiscale ça
c'est par un possible par exemple
normalement en france tous les montages
qui ont pour unique objectif d'éluder
l'impôt peuvent elles tant ses seins
peuvent être requalifiés en a bu en abus
de droit fiscal et du coup en fraude
donc après faut aller chercher les
l'émondage et les examinons szymon de
frau spitz fraude fiscale si on risque
beaucoup pas beaucoup c'est simplement
une petite tape derrière la tête c'est
quoi ces montants on risque beaucoup
c'est un
passé les mêmes peines
revenons à nos moutons j'ai beaucoup de
questions concernant blast et concerne
un anticorps donc on va commencer par
anticor
vous avez reçu un peu de pognon un peu
beaucoup même
64 mille euros en 2020 doki
quelqu'un non maintenant tout le monde
connaît le nom s'appelle rd16 vous devez
rencontrer que bon je les rencontre et
je vais rencontrer quand j'ai pris la
présidence d'anticorps puisque il
donnait déjà de l'argent à l'association
depuis combien de temps
il a donné alors il a donné cinq mille
euros en 2017 vingt mille euros en 2018
et 64 mille euros en 2020 donc ça fait
quatre ans
qu'est-ce qui vous la présenter
balleux
je crois qu'il a demandé il a demandé
[Musique]
à avoir un coup de fil avec moi pour me
dire salut au oui pour se présenter il
nous file quand même
enfin il nous fallait ou non fils est ce
que c'est normal
ainsi moi par exemple je veux votre
numéro de téléphone je mets cinquante
mille balles sur la table jeudi je veux
lui mais rodez disent non vous pouvez
juste envoyer un message sympa
j'avais compris ma question sur ma liste
je peux journalisme est ce que c'est
normal que moi je l'appelle pour lui
pour dire bonjour je suis la nouvelle
présidente qui l'avait appelé c'est lui
qui vous a appelé
alors
bon je sais pas comment ça s'est passé
je crois qu'il a peut-être un peu l'oeil
bien mahi la tête envoyer un message
j'imagine pour dire bah quand vous aurez
quand vous aurez élu un nouveau
président
j'appellerais pour pour dire bonjour
normal de faire ça
ben je trouve pas ça exagéré oui deux
cantons contribuer à cette hauteur là
un
combat c'est peut-être oui normal de
savoir à qui on confie
à qui on confie son argent pour pour
lutter contre la corruption qui l'avait
un peu envie de
savoir quelle était ma vision ma vision
d'anticorps crois ce que j'avais
ce que j'allais faire ce que j'avais
fait avec son argent
c'est pas normal normal bon moi si je
vous donne un bureau ouais
je vais pas pouvoir avoir un traitement
de faveur si j'en ai 50 milles est ce
qu'on peut avoir dix neuf en restant
non
comprenez ma question provoque oui oui
je la comprends
je la comprends moi je ne crois pas
on voyait pas lui dire non en fait ben
non je veux pas
c'est quand même pas anodin de de donner
5000 euros à une association par mois il
n'y a pas beaucoup il n'y a pas beaucoup
de personnes qui font ça je comprendre
de son côté il va et qu'on s'assure je
pense qu'on est sérieux qu'on a eu on a
une vision quand on est motivé qu'on
n'utilise pas son argent pour faire des
voyages aux maldives
c'est pas un fils qui ressemble à ça
s'appelle pas propositions indécentes on
connaissait ce film a un style bien un
mec qui te propose un million à
quelqu'un pour avoir une soirée que sa
femme
voilà ça s'éloigne quand même un petit
peu de
gens de soi situation quand vous êtes
une association soi-disant et les moines
bénédictins de l'anti corruption
c'est pas normal ça c'est pas normal
d'avoir ou civil avec avec un donateur
ça vous a pas eu bien peu partout non
parce que moi le pour moi anticorps
c'est une asso de bénévoles en fait
c'était plus facile à entrer dans une
association bénévole non à rentrer avant
de rentrer et non six mois je calcule
par rapport à combien de travail combien
d'heures de travail je fais et
bénévolement tous les jours pour
anticorps
je multiplie sa part mon taux horaire
façon dont il est ridicule en fait les
ridicules jeu chez pour moi c'est
beaucoup plus important qu'un membre du
bureau
craque pas soit content soient contents
de l'association de son boulot que que
n'importe quel donateurs soient contents
de l'activité d'anticorps
d'ailleurs on est
nous on fait on on paye avec nos payes
avec les cotisations de nos adhérents
les salaires de nos deux salariés le
loyer de notre local et des contrats
fixes en gros qu'on peut pas annuler
dans l'année donc en fait si et s'il y
avait un problème avec un donateur il
prend la porte puis notation n'a pas la
personnalité tu te fous de
d'accepter ne serait ce que des
commentaires quoi donc plus que ça donc
qu'est-ce qui vous a dit des choses
bon je crois qu'il s'est présenté il m'a
dit pourquoi est-ce-que
pourquoi est ce qu'ils donnaient
anticorps ou que lui dans le dans sa vie
des affaires il avait vu
il avait vu des réseaux corruptif hyper
grave
nous a dit aussi qu'il pensait qu'on ce
qu'on se bat avec des dix épée en bois
chez les brins d'herbe
que en gros on se voit on se bat et
qu'aucun moyen contre des réseaux qui
ont des moyens quasiment illimitées
et qui sont hyper bien structuré et que
l'on fait un peu de la peine
un peu de la peine avec notre budget et
notre association de bénévoles que nous
on aime bien mais bon voilà donc
je pense qu'il trouve qu'on a fait du
bon boulot
du coup il a dit bon ben ok
ok je vous donne juste un de 5000 euros
par mois
je suis à peu près de 1500 euros net
pour un salarié c'est ça
ah bah non parce que oui enfin si vous
voulez mais en fait c'est son argent il
est mis de côté il n'est pas impactée au
but à ce budget-là de l'association donc
en fait non
d'ailleurs
quand quand lui il a voulu donner plus
d'argent on a eu quand même un débat ou
plus c'est aller jusqu'à 700 mille euros
beaucoup d'un coup parce que discutable
pour lui
alors oui dans une certaine limite pas
du tout dans la limite de sept cent
mille euros je crois pas je crois que
c'est comme
c'est comme pour le reste des déductions
c'est à dire qu'on peut défiscalisé à
hauteur de 66 % dans la limite de 20% de
son impôt sur les revenus
et en fait lui il a il a voulu nous
donner plus d'argent nous y mais écoutez
vous allez vendre plus de juristes vous
avez besoin de bateaux cela me fait de
la peine en gros à vous battre contre
des géants avec des moyens
des moyens tout petit et moi je lui dis
bah non en fait non on n'acceptera
jamais qu'un poste de salarié soit
financée par an dont on n'acceptera pas
ça parce que on veut on veut pas se
retrouver dans la position de devoir
licencier
si jamais il ya un désaccord
si jamais il ya un désaccord et que et
que vous nous menace si vous pensez
qu'il est temps d'arrêter vos dons on
veut pas se retrouver dans une situation
où nous on doit virer quelqu'un du coup
il m'a dit d'accord donc si je suis
votre raisonnement il faudrait peut-être
financer tout ça à l'avance si vous
voulez moi je vous donne trois postes 4
en avance
et sur quoi moi je lui ai répondu bah
non en fait on ne peut pas accepter
autant d'argent déjà je suis pas
certaine qu'on en ait besoin et en plus
de ça ça représente deux fois notre
budget annuel impossible impossible
donc on n'a pas arrêté de dire non
c'était insistant
non je crois que il a
peut-être de lui des difficultés à
comprendre en fait pourquoi on faisait
son argent
sans qui ce mec soit qu'ils disent mais
attendez vous n'avez pas confiance en
moi vous croyez que je vais essayer de
vous influencer voudrait que j'ai essayé
de vous trahir de vous mettre dans une
salle position chez moi je crois pas je
prends des décisions de principe pour
défendre l'indépendance d'anticorps et
tout le monde est d'accord avec moi dans
l'association je pense que maintenant il
a compris
comprenez pas à l'époque mais mais là ça
fait ça fait des mois qu'il est traqué
dans les médias donc j'imagine qu'il a
compris
le fait de recevoir de l'argent qui fait
partie de l'optimisation fiscale ça pose
une question éthique ou pas je crois
enfin je pense pas que ça d'argent fait
partie de l'eau vient de l'optimisation
fiscale j'en sais rien en tout cas c'est
une personne qui lui fait de qui lui
fait de l'optimisation fiscale
alors la réponse à ça c'est elle est
délicate moi je dis pas que c'est ma
position là est facile
en gros nous ce qu'on protège c'est
l'indépendance d'anticorps ça on protège
évidemment là c'est pas une question
d'indépendance puisque non là on a
limité les dons plus on vient de re
limiter les dons on a prévu des
mécanismes de publication la question là
c'est là c'est la moralité
nous nous ce qu'on se dit c'est que
micro pardon désolé nous ce qu'on se
soit on se dit c'est que c'est pas
impossible qu'une personne profite du
système évalue le veulent de changer
que il n'a pas tort de dire qu'on se bat
avec très peu de moyens contre contre
des systèmes
corruptif mafieux ultra puissant
et qu' il n'y a pas un système fiscal
spécial pour les adhérents pour les
adhérents d'anticorps c'est nous ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on dit aux états
qu'il faut changer ça
ah bah si on vit ici l'argent à loder
quant à elle vient de notre action dans
l'infraction pénale évidemment ce mec la
demande de ce que moi j'ai compris mais
je suis pas son expert comptable et je
suis pas son porte parole non plus
mais de ce que j'ai compris ce qui me
dit il fait aucune aucune fraude fiscale
il a eu les payent des impôts en france
beaucoup
tout cas c'est bon ben je sais pas je
suis pas demandé je vais pas passer mes
journées au téléphone avec lui un jeu
chez
moi j'ai cru en sa sincérité quand il
m'a dit que il voulait lutter contre la
corruption
il n'a jamais cherché à influencer
anticorps et s'ils l'avaient fait ils se
seraient priées important dans la gueule
ça c'est très clair et
et puis je crois je crois aussi que les
personnes oui peuvent profiter d'un
système et le trouvais injuste et
vouloir se planta et pourquoi on ne
trouve pas la liste des gros donateurs
celle anticorps à on publie pas du tout
ni la lizonne aux donateurs ni la liste
de nos adhérents alors maintenant ça va
changer parce que du coup on a on a on a
adopté un système qui est hyper complexe
mais bon maintenant
les personnes pourront pas donner plus à
anticor +2 7% des recettes elles - un
sens que leurs noms soient publiées dans
le rapport financier et non rap notre
rapport financier n'en rapportent nos
rapports moraux sont sur notre site
internet vous avez tous les chiffres
d'anticorps notre comptabilité sur le
site aussi un petit scénario là est-ce
que vous pensez que vous n'avez pas eu
votre agréé bron parce que imaginez-vous
la dgsi enquête sur sur vous se
rencontrent que y'a un mec qui fait de
l'optimisation fiscale à singapour
luxembourg citent 8 la dgsi appelle le
cabinet du ministre ils disent attention
ingérence
potentiel dans les élections de l'état
on a un milliardaire qui s'amusa
survitaminé des associations qui
cherchent des poux à notre bonne classe
politique
attention attention réétudier leur
agrément est-ce que ça ça peut tenir
debout
cette méfiance concernant votre agrément
du fait qu'ils aient de l'argent qui
puisse arriver comme ça je sais pas
s'ils se méfient tout aussi s'ils
cherchent des failles on n'a pas besoin
de donateurs pour pur jus thimphu
d'imaginer ça alors
moi je pense qu'il ya probablement de
une espèce de paranoïa et
et une peur de la trahison dans
[Musique]
dans le gouvernement très très
certainement mais bon ça ça me regarde
pas vraiment en fait moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est qu'il ya cinq
conditions pour avoir l'agrément et
parmi ces conditions il ya
l'indépendance l'indépendance de
l'association notamment au regard de ces
ressources et il
n'y a aucune raison que parce qu'une
personne fait de l'optimisation fiscale
on considère que l'association de manque
d'indépendance ce qui est constituée de
personnes a des liens financiers aussi
avec doute parti politique avec d'autres
partis politiques doutent personnel
politique
ouais on n'est pas comme si on n'est pas
un parti politique
si cette personne a des liens battant
que tant qu'elle est elle fait pas
pression sur l'anticorps tant que nous
n'avons pas notre activité contre contre
des sous en fait non la question n'est
pas de l'activité que nous ferons des
sous
ben non
ça peut être interprété au sycoscan oh
bah non non non pourquoi ce serait
interprété comme ça on a pensé avons été
sur y coûte
je les pensais oui beaucoup parce que
mon téléphone fait vraiment plein de
bruits bizarres
mi koné pa en technologie
mais j'ai quand même
beaucoup d'étranges bruits sur mon
téléphone mais je sais pas si c'est un
signe d'être sur écoute ou pas
d'ailleurs je veux bien des conseils si
quelqu'un veut vraiment donner je
voudrais une parenthèse le boycott n'est
pas interdit en france a
aussi un article 225-1 et
225-2 du code pénal bon bah on s'y met
tous à la donc revenons à nos moutons
l'optimisation fiscale les sous des sous
qui viennent de loin
accordons accordons-nous sur sur le
bénéfice du doute concernant ce généreux
bienfaiteurs
est ce que vous le fait de le faire
rentrer ou le faire approcher l'équipe
de blast c'était d'erreurs
non non le mettre en relation est là je
pense pas moi le ce qui s'est passé en
fait c'est que il nous il voulait nous
donner beaucoup plus d'argent que ce
qu'on plus bas je voulais dit ils
voulaient nous a proposé un moment tiko
oui anticorps et pour bost ah bah ça
c'est ça c'est une autre question ce que
je voulais vous dire c'est que quand il
vit a voulu nous proposer tout cet
argent moi j'ai dit non évidemment est
arrivée comment par quel cheminement par
quel content donc en cachons vaghi c'est
ce que vous faites comme certains
politiques qui se font attraper gare du
nord avec des valises de cash
non non ce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait la
seule chose qu'on arrive à faire parce
que vont ils sont marrant mais bon on
n'est quand même pas le fisc milani la
dgsi ni la dgse
avait reçu dès que nous on contrôle on
contrôle juste que ça vient d'un compte
bancaire français
d'une personne physique en gros on
n'accepte pas les noms des personnes on
n'accepte pas aller dans des entreprises
on n'accepte pas les subventions
publiques or la seule chose qu'on
accepte en termes de financement c'est
les personnes physiques
et aussi les personnes morales à but non
lucratif et encore ça c'est validé par
le conseil d'administration donc on
accepte des personnes physiques qui
vient d'un compte bancaire personnel
domiciliés en france le reste oui pour
anticorps vous avez jamais reçue en
cadeau des choses comme ça déboite de
céder du vin des bagues des billets
d'avion et là non
pourtant j'ai besoin de vacances je
pense que c'est évident mais non
revenons à blast est ce que c'était pas
une erreur de présenter quelqu'un qui
fait de l'optimisation fiscale
un média qui est sensé
about est présenté
j'ai présenté ainsi dire à denis robert
je crois que c'était en octobre
je ne l'étais pas je n'étais pas du tout
au fond
j'étais pas du tout au courant en fait
de ces montages moi la seule chose que
je savais c'est qu'on avait vérifié
qu'il a son compte bancaire était en
france c'est tout et je vais présenter
parce que en fait nous refusons cet
argent je lui ai dit tu m'a demandé si
je pouvais faire pas prêt
à penser à nous mais c'est un scandale
vous n'aurez pas accepter mais j'aurais
pu j'aurais pu en fait parce que moi
j'ai un don a déjà il nous a déjà
proposé du pognon pour nous financer et
renato non pas des valises des gros
chèques on a toujours refusé d'ailleurs
parce que on n'en voulait pas et surtout
on a une expert comptable de combat
qui ne laisse rien passer avait il ya
c'est hors de question mais même pour
nous était hors de question c'est même
avec un contrat comme quoi il avait
aucune décision punk en brousse étaient
des sous non on n'en veut pas pourquoi
vous
connaissances à vous présenter ce un
autre
parce qu'il y avait 700 mille balles qui
devait être d'éclat qui eut tant que ça
serve à quelqu'un va moi je sais déjà je
ne savais pas je voulais les restos du
coeur ce n'est pas bien les seuls car
bon pourquoi pas aussi moi je en fait
lui lui sont le sens de ce financement
c'est qu' il veut lutter contre la
corruption donc donc voilà ici je veux
aider à au paiement de repas de
personnes je pense qu'il sait très bien
où elle est tout seul cette semaine
sainte et sacrée tripotée de repas quand
même non ah bah oui ce serait très bien
mais d'ailleurs pense qu'il a il a plus
d'argent que ça donc s'il a envie qui
donne d'ailleurs tous les risques que
les riches de ne plus agir bien combien
il a bipé
je ne sais pas j'ai entendu des
personnes qui m'ont dit qu'ils étaient
presque milliardaire
personne ne peut savoir
je n'ai même pas lu les articles sur ces
montages est ce que vous comprenez le
sens de mes questions je vous pousse ça
pour que les choses soient très claires
qui est un milliardaire philanthrope ont
déjà milliardaire et philanthrope dans
la même phrase c'est compliqué et qu'il
apprenne un milliardaire qui décidé
d'aider son pays pour faire monter des
associations qui traque les corrompus
qui traque le détournement de pognon on
se dit ok mais peut-être que dans un
coin de notre tête on peut se dire ils
souhaitent aussi vous donner soit le
baiser de la mort
soit vous instrumentalisez soit servir
son propre agenda
oui notre premier réflexe quand on a
quelqu'un qui nous soutient
financièrement c'est pas de se dire
qu'il est là pour nous couler un
peut-être qu'on est là et
non du premier réflexe est de se dire
qu'a priori il et il est d'accord avec
nos combats et de toute façon
instrumentalisé anticorps bas comment
comment il pourrait faire ça et je sais
puisque vous avez dit nous couler baby
damman ce serait un peu spécial de se
dire qu'il nous a aidés financièrement
pour finalement que ça mange des médias
quand il va sur glace tu sais ça grâce à
vous fait entrer le loup dans la
bergerie
oui je les ai présenté parce que parce
que de niveaux que ça devait être en
octobre parce que denier avait décidé de
créer son média donc je les ai présenté
en expliquant qu'en gros bas le travail
que fait anticorps très souvent on le
fait sur la base d'investigations en
gros
si si il faut aider la lutte
anti-corruption en gros il faut aider
les médias qui enquête sur ça mais il y
en a il y en a pas mal qui le font et
qu'ils le font très bien donc pas ce que
vous avez senti quand même sept
personnes voulant donner de l'argent
avec avait avait ses motivations la
wii oui bien sûr oui
oui il y en a il ya un discours qui est
cohérent après bon bah c'est enfin j'ai
passé une demi heure à parler de
quelqu'un parce qu'ils financent parce
qu'ils financent anticorps je préfère
voir ce que les gens pensent aux actions
maximum et dany
comprise non
non je la trouve hallucinante
après on est en train d'essayer de
comprendre donc peut-être que peut-être
que bientôt on aura plus d'informations
maxime renahy ce qu'ils disent et qu' il
s'est battu tout seul contre
contrebas l'acceptation des du
financement de cette de cette personne
de donateurs je suis habitué à pas dire
son nom
que il a
quand il s'est battu sur la question de
des salaires et du plafonnement des
salaires et je sait plus sur quel sur
quel angle et ils s'attribuent
complètement
le monopole de ces batailles ski ça est
vraiment de malhonnêteté intersidéral
parce que que ce soit les refus de don
encore une fois puisque
puisque finalement bas ce donateur il a
donné vingt mille euros c'est pas rien
mais par rapport à par rapport à ce
qu'ils auraient pu financer vu sa
fortune bon c'est quand même pas
assez c'est pas énorme non plus or la
décision de refuser l'argent c'est une
décision qui a été prise collectivement
quasiment à l'unanimité sauf denis denis
denis les live ou 10 mai venez sous les
riches donnez-moi plein d'argent je plie
à personne je ferai mes enquêtes et très
bien parce que c'est un impératif parce
qu'il sait qu'il est il est
incorruptible les ouvriers le pognon
s'est il est super sincère si les super
sincère il est super naturel il fera
toujours les enquêtes qu'il en a envie
de faire toujours c'est quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire d'ailleurs il a pas de
filtre
passe son temps à dire les choses il les
sait pas c'est pas un stratège vie il
est très naturel
alors question internet anti corps at il
déjà enquêté sur ce il qu review ben non
c'est ici gdj s'y arrête
non non on accepte d'aller un peu
partout en fait il ya eu un moment où
des administrateurs ont commencé à dire
non faut pas qu'on aille sur 4 tel
plateau tel plateau on a fini par mettre
les choses à plat et dire en fait nous
on va on va là où on nous invite parce
que on a des choses à dire et qu'il ya
des personnes à informer et à convaincre
partout dans toutes les audiences au
maximum
i que ce fameux donateurs étaient contre
la gpa ou avait l'air très intéressé par
le sujet de la gpa ou qu'il voulait
qu'on diligente des enquêtes sur hidalgo
que l'était un peu envie guahma qui avec
arnaud montebourg
ça vous fait quoi c'est
bah
ouais c'est pas vrai d'où est-ce que ça
sort
alors c'est vrai c'est maxime qui le dit
je ne sais pas si ça a été contredit par
pardonner
il parle je pense d'une réunion
qui a eu lieu tout début décembre moi je
suis resté dix minutes un quart d'heure
donc je ne sais pas ce qui a été dit
après
ce qui a été dit avant et sage les
succès que
cette personne-là avait envisagé de
soutenir arnaud montebourg s'il se
présentait je crois comprendre que ce
n'est plus le cas dire moi je m'en moque
en fait
je m'en moque c'est pas parce qu'il
soutient un candidat ou quoi que ce soit
que ce façon que ça va influencer
décision du conseil d'administration
d'anticorps
connaissent déjà ils le connaissent pas
ils le connaissent pas en fait
il ya eu une information
du bureau certes mais
nous on a une politique de
confidentialité qui fait que le nom des
donateurs il est peut être transmis si
besoin à nos salariés et aux membres du
bureau s'il ya besoin et puis bah
d'autres prestataires prestataires
informatiques
donc en fait le conseil d'administration
est pas informée du nom des donateurs
plus on en a mille six cent donc
moi je ne suis pas du tout informé non
plus du don des donateurs c'est juste
que s'ils donnent plus d'un certain
montant
là on va leur poser un peu plus de
questions s'assurer que c'est bien
voilà basique quoi avec les avec ce
qu'on a comme arbre c'est à dire poser
des questions avoir des réponses on ne
diligente pas d' enquête sur nos
donateurs pas du tout est ce que si un
donateur vous demande de vous intéresser
plus untel ou untel
à balai il va arrêter de donner dans la
seconde
il va il va se faire [__] dehors ça
c'est sûr
question internet vous êtes plutôt
macron bourg
bof
pas vraiment venu pour parler de mes
opinions politiques
accepter
alors nous on nous pose une question qui
vous a proposé des gros chèques alors il
y avait un producteur télé et des gens
qui travaillent dans l'audiovisuel mais
c'est comme intéressé
préfère avoir notre communauté qui nous
finance et nous contrairement anticorps
nos gros donateurs et ben il soumet mme
régine que tous les autres et son public
ils sont sûrs tipi mais doux c'est pas
parce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui fait nous
des milles par la drac un traitement de
faveur ok oui mais enfin bon un
traitement de faveur moi j'aurais j'ai
toute la journée des militants et des
adhérentes et les vols on s'est compris
ban si je pose 50 milles sur la table et
je demande vous dire si ce sera fera pas
le même effet que si c'est quelqu'un qui
vous met dix balles sur la table aussi
c'est quelqu'un qui m'envoie un message
sympa d'encouragement et qui propose un
projet anticorps chouette de développer
six palettes interventions dans les
lycées de faire un escape game on ne
sait pas quoi vous vous dis millions
d'euros parce que je peux vous acheter
pour 10 millions d'euros ht moi
personnellement
20 millions
moi je suis joue les ij pas très pas
j'ai pas besoin de beaucoup d'argent
pour y vivre
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire de
cette histoire avec max hybrid haï qui
s'énerve de son côté blast qui obligeait
d'un époux cette querelle
ce que je sais c'est que la version de
maxime tient pas debout du trou
bah non je conçois c'est objectivement
elle tient pas debout parce que lui il
dit qu'il a claqué la porte parce que il
a il a enquêté sur hervé vinciguerra et
que et qui l'a alerté sur sur ses avoirs
financiers et qu' il n'a pas accepté ça
et qu'il a claqué la porte sauf qu'entre
temps il ya eu trois mois et il a
continué à travailler avec blast sur la
campagne la ilaha illa est devenue
salariée de glace pendant je crois qu il
nous ressort des trucs réchauffés que ce
n'est pas la vraie raison
question internet comment régler le
problème des listes des paradis fiscaux
est-ce que c'est pas un peu du foutage
de gueule de met un coup gris coupe
agria couloir compas loire
ah bah oui c'est surtout qu'il ya des
paradis fiscaux en fait au sein de
l'union européenne mais
bon cette liste des paradis fiscaux
finalement à à quoi elle sert elle sert
à avoir l'attestation je crois la de
régularité mais c'est pas c'est pas salé
ce qu'il faut faire pour pour lutter
contre l'optimisation et la fraude dans
l'union européenne
il faut il faut harmoniser pour
harmoniser le taux de l'assiette
d'imposition il faut harmoniser la tva
et il faut créer un plancher
d'imposition commune pour les presser
pour les sociétés parce qu'il ya plein
de société qui paye pas un franc 1 franc
fin je suis vieille 1 euro 1 euros
d'arrhes beau succès non non non ba
avait longtemps j'avais le france et le
rosser 2001
taille ce qui leur est ce qu'il fout de
vous dire un loup pour combattre les
loups
bah ça c'est ce que pense denis robert
c'est à dire que il faut se battre avec
les armes des autres
nous on se passe qu'on pense à anticor
dont on se bat avec nos armes à nous et
chacun son rôle
par exemple dans le fonctionnement de la
justice nous notre rôle c'est d'envoyer
des signalements saisir le procureur
saisir un juge d'instruction si jamais
si jamais ça la justice suit pas son
cours normal par contre par exemple on
n'est pas là pour n'est pas là pour
condamner ça c'est le tribunal qui le
fèvre chacun son rôle et nous on a
intervient dans dans le rôle qu'on sait
qu'on s'est attribué que la loi nous
attribue aussi puisque
l'agrément est prévue par la loi si je
vous dis la meilleure façon de se venger
d'un ennemi c'est de ne pas lui
ressembler c'est qu'ils agissent et à
marc aurèle
on arrive à la fin de notre interview
est-ce que vous avez trois bouts tient
un conseiller d'autres communautés
sur la corruption sur ce que vous voulez
sur ce que je veux
moi j'ai été très très fans à dos
d'oriana fallaci
j'ai adorer
l'être à un enfant jamais né
j ai adoré un homme
et
et pénélope ô pénélope part en guerre je
crois que c'était ça le titre
voilà récemment j'ai lu ar je me
souviens plus du nom de l'auteur c'est
l'homme qui parlait la langue des
serpents magnifique
je vous donne pas de bouquins sur la
corruption parce que je trouve que c'est
bien aussi de voyager un petit peu
peut-être plus mais bon allez un bouquin
sur la corruption
l'ancien président du cor a écrit un
bouquin qui est qui et qui est ma ma
bible qui est sur ma table de chevet on
oublie de parler d'un truc
la corruption à l'étranger pareil par
exemple avec des boîtes françaises
qui sont obligés de verser des pots de
vin ensuite comme ils font ça n'importe
comment ils se font attraper par les
américains et puis ça arrange bien les
américains alex prémat et l'extra
territorialité de de leurs droits
est ce que la france n'est pas un peu
sous dotées pour se battre avec des pays
qui n'hésite pas à colombe qui n'hésite
pas ensuite à utiliser le fait que la
france a pu traîner dans les vagues ou
les boîtes françaises ont pu traîner
dans des dossiers de corruption
pour faire plier ses banques la ccc
d'ailleurs les banques ces entreprises
là comment anticorps perçoit là le jeu
et l'échiquier international de la
corruption en termes de géopolitique de
la corruption
c'est devenu une une arme de guerre
économique en fait c'est surtout ça le
problème après là aujourd'hui il me
semble qu'il ya quatre ou cinq pays qui
ont décidé que leurs droits et leur
justice serait extrait extraterritoriale
pour des des cas de corruption je suis
désolé je me suis je serai plus vous
dire c'est pas forcément que des gros
pays d'ailleurs le problème c'est que si
tout le monde fait ça en fait
on met fin à la territorialité de la
justice et du coup on se retrouve avec
des situations où si vous utilisez telle
monnaie si vous utilisez telle société
je crois que si on passe par facebook
twitter ce genre de société de
communication qui finalement rattache
les entreprises
gironde de la justice américaine en fait
qu'est ce qui va se passer une société
elle va être potentiellement pouvoir
être jugée par part de 150 pays
donc c'est très compliqué mais c'est
surtout que ce qui était une loi
peut-être à la base américaine qui avait
vocation à à lutter contre la corruption
s'est transformé en un clairement on a
un outil de guerre économique c'est à
dire que le department of justice des
états unis finalement cible très
clairement des entreprises qui
représentent un intérêt stratégique et
dont il
aimerait bien qu'une société américaine
rachète donc vous avez une entreprise
comme beaucoup d'entreprises elle a filé
des pots de vin ou plus ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est à dire pas des pots de
vin on paye des intermédiaires pour
aller approchez approchez des décideurs
publics
et bah on arrête on arrête un grand
dirigeant qui s'est passé avec richie
dans le dossier
dans le dossier alsthom
et puis bon
donne une amende à ces sociétés qui la
met quand même en difficulté
économiquement ça tombe bien parce que
ça baisse ça baisse son prix de rachat
pour l'entreprise qui débarque derrière
et est proposé un proposé un rachat et
oui il faut que faut que la france
s'arme pour sa très clairement mais sur
ces sujets là c'est c'est difficile
d'avoir une solution parce qu'en fait
ce qu'il faudrait en soit c'est que tous
les pays lutte contre la corruption chez
eux et qu'on se retrouve pas avec des
débordements de
de la terrible parler de l'extra
territorialité de partout parce que ça
va être un sacré bazar et puis sachant
que du coup il ya de l'argent à la clé
que c'est pas c'est pas des petites
sommes c'est peut-être un business dans
lequel plusieurs ce plusieurs pays vont
s'engouffrer il me semble que
l'angleterre le fait déjà je crois
vous lire ajouter des choses sur la
grille bon de l'anticorps
ben oui oui moi je
sais je pense qu'on avait on s'était dit
que ce serait peut-être difficile parce
que parce qu'il ya eu la sphère ferrand
et la sphère colère on a compris je
crois qu'on agacé le pouvoir très
fortement
mais ce qui se passe en ce moment c'est
c'est une riposte d'une violence
vraiment vraiment surprenante
moi j'ai ça fait un mois et demi que je
suis je suis attaqué de partout
anticorps aussi
alors ça a commencé par un journal qui
s'appelle causeur qui a qui a dit que
j'avais commis un parjure c'est à dire
qu'il a dit que j'avais menti devant la
représentation nationale nationale ça a
été repris par un député puis par
d'autres journaux par le jdd par le
point ce truc
les fondeurs
ouais moi j'aime pas j'aime pas c'est
difficile de bien
non c'est faux c'est complètement faux à
moi pour vous dire j'ai tendance à je
suis même allé voir un avocat pour pour
me le faire confirmer je me suis dit
mais c'est pas possible que
que des journaux qu'un député
relais des caisses des accusations de
parjure dire
moi je suis un bénévole on est tous
bénévoles ont fait on fait un boulot que
le gouvernement devrait faire et on le
fait avec pas beaucoup de moyens on
s'est rendu en mai devant l'assemblée
devant l'assemblée nationale on avait
bossé pendant trois jours montceau serra
coup en fait expliqué de notre
communauté l'agrément ça sert à empêcher
que des affaires de corruption soit
enterré c'est ce qui s'est passé dans le
dossier ferrand dossier ferrand il était
classé à brest on allait le chercher le
dossier colère il a été classé au parc
national financiers c'est un dossier
qu'on allait chercher aussi maintenant
ces deux dossiers sont devant un juge
d'instruction
voilà ça sert à ça l'agrément c'est
hyper important il faut absolument qu'on
l'ait je pense que si on a des
difficultés actuellement c'est qu'on a
en trop bien fait notre boulot et que le
reste basse et des opérations de
déstabilisation
pour créer du doute en fait et
et préparer l'opinion à un non
renouvellement et ça il faut pas le
laisser faire parce que votre
interprétation oui bah oui je vous donne
mon interprétation je pense que ça c'est
une grosse campagne de déstabilisation
et que
et que finalement j'entends absolument
personne qui nous fait des critiques sur
comment on met nos dossiers par exemple
bah oui il ya des gens qui nous disent
au départ web à vous porter plainte
beaucoup contre la droite on dit bah non
en fait à les regarder sur notre site
internet regarder nos dossiers c'est
faux on a porté plainte contre
contre des élus de gauche aussi on a
aucun souci à le faire
et
voilà on va continuer à faire ce bon
boulot moi je pense qu'il est il est
vraiment nécessaire dans une dans une
démocratie on a besoin de ça on est en
démocratie nous quand on est en
démocratie défaillante pas c'est
officiel c'est ce que dit l'économiste a
dit hadi sur la france et je pense qu'on
a on perd des contre-pouvoirs les
contrats contrats pouvoir les
contre-pouvoirs sont énormément attaquer
en france on aime ou on n'aime pas les
gilet jaune moi je suis pas venu pour
vous donner un positionnement politique
en revanche je suis choquée mais j'étais
choqué de dès le départ sur la manière
dont des citoyens qui ont des
revendications politiques ont été
malmenés
frapper
il y en a qui ont perdu des membres
enfin je trouve ça hallucinant avec
votre ange avec nous ouais mais là c'est
même plus l'enjeu en fait c'est même
plus l'enjeu l'enjeu c'est c'est la
santé des personnes la possibilité pour
des citoyens d'aller dans la rue avec
des relents tessier revendications
politiques et moi je suis extrêmement
choquée de ça je vous dis pas que je
soutiens forcément leurs revendications
politiques même si je les soutenais pas
je m'en fous je veux être dans un pays
où les citoyens peuvent sortir dans la
rue et manifester et dire qu'ils en ont
marre et s'il ya des débordements bas
ils doivent être gérés dans
avec le moins deux usages de la force
possible on a on a parlé à placer des
sujets qui ont été traitées très
tardivement par les médias ce qu'il a
fallu attendre huit mois pour que pour
que bfm parle de violences policières
c'est quand même huit mois x 4 it s 32
32 manif à peu près peut-être plus pour
que bfm parle de ça il va ça chauffe ça
hyper hyper choquant et si si ils
avaient
revendiqué la traite des humains j'ai
passé un bon exemple je crois que
j'aurais quand même protéger leur droit
de
revendiquer quoi de d'aller dans la rue
si les citoyens peuvent plus manifester
si on respecte plus les libertés
fondamentales
on est plus en démocratie et je pense
que s'il ya aussi un gros problème avec
les médias
de liberté de la presse de plus rite
pluralité de la presse et que ça c'est
quand même très compliqué et ça ça a un
impact parce que ça ça forge
ça forge l'opinion des citoyens et quand
on se retrouve avec tous les plateaux
télé qui disent que c'est grave d'avoir
tant d'années sarkozy à un an de prison
ferme pour trafic d'influencé et
corruption je étonné
étonné qu'il ait finalement il n'y a
qu'une qu'une version
une version sur dans beaucoup de médias
et qu' il n'y a pas beaucoup de voix
dissonantes et puis il ya les
associations et en ce moment il ya plein
de trucs à dire parce qu'ils sont en
train de bosser sur la vigile
séparatisme sur un espèce d'accord qui
va être proposé un contrat républicain
proposé aux associations
finalement on fait que leur redire ce
qui est prévu dans la loi et je
comprends pas pourquoi pourquoi est ce
qu'on va faire signer un contrat aux
associations en leur disant qu'il faut
respecter l'ordre public bah oui en fait
tout le monde doit respecter l'ordre
public on vient ajouter une espèce de
contractualisation comme s'il fallait
encadrer encadrer l'activité des
associations et ça a été on a dit qu'il
fallait le faire parce que il y avait
des associations cultuelles extrémistes
mais c'est toujours la même chose en
fait on déjà mon à la droite
il ya plein de liberté à respecter dans
ce pays heureusement on a le droit
d'avoir sa religion est un droit plein
de choses et en plus de ça on peut pas
gérer un cas global
on ne peut pas réagir un quinqua globale
en espérant gérer un problème
particulier parce que finalement on se
retrouve à restreindre les libertés
et quand on dit économistes dit que la
france est une démocratie défaillante
oui je pense que ça fait ça fait ma main
au moment que la france est une
démocratie défaillante et c'est pas
toujours intéressant pour les citoyens
de se mêler de la vie publique mais je
crois qu'il va falloir le faire en fait
ce n'est pas que les citoyens le niveau
a vraiment baissé
et que et que maintenant on est plus on
a un peuple qui n'est plus équipe i pour
pour vraiment prendre sa décision en âme
et conscience mais qu'il n'est équipée
maintenant que pour
réagir d'une façon instinctive quand le
niveau devient trop dur à porter abbas
et le seuil de tolérance il ya beaucoup
de choses politiques qui sont qui
dépendent du seuil de tolérance des
personnes que vous entendez copains
soluto lens mais à quel moment a
également pu redonner chine c'est ça à
quel moment on détruit tout oui mais à
quel moment on supporte plus
quel moment on va on en est plus à
manifester
et à crier des slogans et à chanter des
chansons à calmont détruit tout c'est ça
le seul qui
qui
qu'est-ce d'être dépassés on a quand
même eu un mouvement c'est gentil
commandant
parce que
d'autres histoires ou d'école gentil
mais oui bah ya un moment où ça peut
partir moi j'ai vu que dans les dents
les mêmes dans les pays très policée de
l'europe du nord ça a commencé à
chauffer grave
mais il vaut mieux question internet en
2019 anticorps et eu un budget de 150
3984 euros dont convions une moitié
étaient dépensés en forme d'honoraires
avocat 84000 651 euros combien de ces
honoraires était pays où cabinet
d'avocats qui sont des cabinets des
adhérents
des cabinets des adhérents je comprends
pas que je comprends pas la question je
la vis je rappelle combien ce nos
avocats sont adhérents ouais en gros est
ce que c'est il ya pas des cabinets
d'avocats qui en profite pour s'en
mettre un peu dans la poche
d'appel vous choisissez comment vous le
cabinet d'avocats ah ben on met un peu
on met un peu en concurrence l'ont
globalement anticorps est défendu depuis
prague blanc depuis sa création ou
depuis kuala une activité judiciaire par
jérôme karsenti qui a un excellent
pénaliste et qui a porté nos combats
pendant très longtemps qu'il est par
toujours aujourd'hui là il va
il va aller au procès guérini dans
quelques jours
il était au procès du chaufferie de la
défense qui a été qui n'a pas eu lieu
malheureusement il va nous défendre dans
les sondages de l'elysée
enfin bon il a il a les bus c'est notre
avocat aussi dans le
dans la sphère de dupond moretti il a de
très très gros dossier d'anticorps il
les porte depuis très longtemps avec
avec brio et puis on a on a en tout 27
avocat je crois enfin une petite
trentaine d'avocats donc il ya des
avocats qui ont fui d'autres dossiers on
essaye d'aller chercher des avocats à
paris parce qu'il n'y a pas que paris
dans la vie
et est donc est-ce qu'il y en a qui sont
adhérents parmi ses avocats alors nous
on leur dit de ne pas adhérer
on leur dit de ne pas adhérer que ce pas
la même chose et qu'on aimerait
totalement certain qu'ils sont sont
qu'ils adhèrent à ce qu'on fait mais que
ce pas la peine d'être adhérent donc sur
les 20 28 27 28 doit y avoir trois ou
quatre qui sont adhérents une question
du petit arnaud est ce que vous avez
déjà eu des contrôles fiscaux
alors j'ai je j'imagine que ça va venir
pour l'instant ce que j'ai eu c'est des
prêts contrôles fiscaux dire que quand
on est avocat on doit on doit passer par
une société de gestion des intérêts
libéraux
et
contrairement à tous mes camarades de
promo de l'école des avocats
moi j'ai j'en ai eu pas mal j'en ai eu
en fait ils sont déclenchés à partir de
septembre 2019 et je sais je sais pas si
un lien absolument pas donc ça va toutes
réserves mais c'est dans la période où
tous et commencer à se déclencher contre
anticorps là en l'occurrence c'était dix
jours après la mise en examen de richard
ferrand mais bon moi je dis ça comme je
dis rien parce que j'ai absolument pas
de preuves d'un lien mais à partir de là
septembre 2019 j'ai été contrôlé sur
trois années d'exercice et janvier 2020
j'ai failli pleurer
contrôle sur 2019 donc en six mois j'ai
été contrôlé près contrôlé sur quatre
années d'exercice
et surtout qu'en janvier 2020 j'avais
pas fais ma compta jetez pas prêtes de
la faire vu que cela fait quinze jours
avant le moment où je dois payer mes
impôts
non c'est pas les gens conseil de
promeneurs experts comptables oui je
crois que faire si en plus je fais ma
compta en regardant netflix s'est pas
dire non plus qu'on connaît ou d'expert
comptable de coups bas salaires elles
laissent rien passer hockey et moi de
façon j'ai gagné de l'argent dans cette
histoire parce que je suis flamand ni
seule avocate a pas déclaré c'est dèjà
pas mettre ces déjeuners en charge donc
quand j'ai repris ma compta et que
j'avais plus de temps pour la faire
évidemment je facture avec le nom des
gens
comme indiscutables pour les avocats
c'est discutable pour les avocats mais
pour les journalistes aussi
et comme on n'est pas journaliste
question internet comment voit-elle
l'évolution de la corruption à l'avenir
en france son avis sur le futur de la
france
alors de chez
moi j'aimerais bien déjà que qu'on soit
200000 un anticorps dans les mois qui
viennent
ces 35 euros vraiment venus nous
soutenir quand on quand on arrive dans
un procès on il ya un peu cette
impression que les citoyens défoncent
les portes de la salle d'audience c'est
ça qu'on veut faire c'est faire entrer
les citoyens
dans les salles d'audience et porter une
voix et c'est vachement bien ce soit
clair mon sens figuré ça veut dire
réinvestir des citoyens dans le
processus ça c'est c'est notre avocat
qui représente qui représente les
citoyens et ils défoncent pas la porte
ils l'ouvrent et la referme
très gentiment mais il porte une voix il
porte une voie et c'est super de les
entendre plaidé ces personnes là c'est
vraiment bien et l'avenir du pays
moi ce que
ce que ce que j'aimerais c'est que qu'on
arrive à que la justice condamne de
manière suffisante pour que le reste de
la classe politique est vraiment ce coup
c'est un réveil parce que il ya eu
tellement de d'alert est finalement là
on a l'impression qu'ils y en a plein
qui ont toujours pas compris je pense
aussi qu'on va arriver à un moment où il
va falloir faire une refonte plus
importante
de notre démocratie parce que pascal
dysfonctionne clermont
et voilà laisser plus de place aux
citoyens mais ça veut dire aussi que les
citoyens vont devoir s'intéresser à la
chose publique se la réapproprier aller
aller à des réunions à des citoyens
actifs faire ça alors qu'il ya un climat
de
économique délétère que les gens perdent
leur taf que de plus en plus de violence
entre les gens
c'est un peu du wishful thinking
c'est-à-dire allait s'intéresser à la
corruption
on a toujours appris aux gens à déléguer
leur pouvoir maintenant on leur demande
de se réinvestir parce que les délégués
de la classe en fait et ils nous ont eus
ouais bah oui en même temps il faut bien
que ça s'arrête à un moment et en fait
si ça s'arrête il ya plein de choses qui
vont s'améliorer déjà
déjà à être saouls bête mais je pense
que les impôts bas serait très
clairement la pression fiscale
baisserait donc on va payer moins
d'impôts si on a moins de corruption ça
va important puis en plus de ça on va
bénéficier de services publics qui sont
meilleurs donc ça aussi c'est hyper
important et puis voir on va espérer que
tout ce monde là se comporte mieux parce
que finalement quand les élus montrent
l'exemple bahia il ya beaucoup de gens
qui les suivent
si c'était à refaire et ce qu'elle
reprendrait la tête d'anticorps
ah bah oui oui foulée une question du
petit ardi quels sont les plus belles
victoires d'anticorps
je reprendrai la tête d'anticorps oui
même si c'est hyper difficile en même
temps très clairement je ferais pas un
autre un autre mandat d'ailleurs on est
on est plutôt pour le non cumul des
mandats donc c'est très bien
mais je trouve que c'est c'est vraiment
vraiment dur c'est
et incroyablement dur et
il faut quand même être porté par par
quelque chose pour faire ça mais en même
temps il on est plein de bénévoles dans
cet assaut donc je suis pas la seule à
être à être motivé par ce combat si ces
gens veulent venir voir
c'est aussi une asso qu'il ya des enjeux
passionnant les deux les dossiers sont
passionnants les loges les gens sont
super intéressant donc voilà on a plein
de groupes locaux
j'aimerais bien qu'on soit qu'on soit
encore plus nombreux c'est super je lui
réponds aux questions et la deuxième
question j'ai par exemple jusqu'à la
corde ou les plus belles victoires les
plus belles victoires les plus belles
victoires parfois c'est elles sont pas
éclatantes parce que je vous le disais
que nous notre objectif c'est quand même
que les dossiers soient quand il ya un
blocage que les dossiers soient gérées
par des juges d'instruction ont parfois
la plus belle victoire ça va être
ça va être une ordonnance
des juges qui dit qu'il ya lieu à
instruire un air bizarre mais dans la
sphère colère on a tellement on a
bataillé quand même dans ce dossier on a
eu on a eu des gens contre 7 actions
qu'on pensait pas qu'on pensait pas
avoir
quand on n'a pas compris le comportement
on a dans le dossier colère on a on a
quand même batailler pour avoir accès
au dossier grande enquête préliminaire
on s'est rendu compte que dedans il y
avait une lettre d' emmanuel macron qui
disait que alexis kohler n'avait jamais
travaillé dans des dossiers qui
concernaient msc la société détenue en
partie par sa famille on s'est rendu
compte contrôler la la
au milieu ça delattre est intervenu
entre un premier rapport qui étaient à
charge contre alexis colère et qui
disait ok faut y aller et un deuxième
rapport dit définitif tronquée d'une
quinzaine de pages et dans lequel on
disait rien à voir circuler et on a eu
un classement sans suite du parquet
national financier un mois plus tard et
quand on a enfin réussi à avoir le
dossier dans quatre préliminaire et
qu'on voit la lettre des matériels
macron en disant ma attendait il y avait
plein de lettres dans ce dossier déjà
qui disait ça qu'il avait pas qu'il
avait pas bosser sur des dossiers de m
c'est pourquoi est ce que quand c'est
emmanuel macron qui le dit ça change la
donne pourquoi est-ce que le pnf classe
le dossier
pourquoi est ce que l'inspecteur de la
brd eux laissent cette lettre dans le
dossier aussi
et quand on a vu ça en janvier
c'était en janvier 2020 on décide de se
constituer partie civile c'est-à-dire de
saisir un juge d'instruction et là
encore le parquet national financier a
pris des réquisitions de nous instruire
dire qu'il a demandé au juge de ne pas
ouvrir d'instruction
et les juges ont décidé qu'ils allaient
inscrire donc ça c'est complexe à
expliquer c'est un peu long mais ça
c'est soit là c'est une victoire après
on a obtenu des condamnations je pense
que la condamnation de paul de paul
giacobbi qui est qui est devenue
définitive donc là j'ai même pas de
souci de diffamation je peux vous dire
que c'est un délinquant
il a été condamné définitivement
ça c'était une victoire c'était un
c'était un procès depuis longtemps mené
par anticor depuis longtemps
on a aussi obtenu d'autres condamnations
de on a obtenu la condamnation de
mathieu gallet en première instance il a
fait appel des présumés innocents on a
eu la condamnation de marc
martial passi qui était qui était maire
de givors j'ignore s'il est encore
d'ailleurs qui est un élu
un élu de gauche
et qui a fait appel aussi également de
toute façon dont procède sur dix ans
attention politique des prétentions
politiques vous comptez vous présenter
au jour non est-ce que vous avez un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
bouteille à la mer
stade où ils en sont moi je dirais de
diversifier les sources d'aller voir des
médias des médias indépendants
c'est c'est le plus intéressant qu'ils
peuvent faire pour forger une opinion
après je pense que l'école républicaine
fait déjà quand même pas mal ce boulot
là
mais si en dehors en dehors de ça ils
veulent forger des opinions la forêt
faut aller vous diversifier les médias
allaient voir pleins d'autres médias et
j'en profite pour dire que si on est
ravis quand ce sera possible de nouveau
d'intervenir dans l'est dans les lycées
ont
fait ça via le mécanisme de la réserve
citoyenne
du coup pas s'il ya des profs qui ont
envie qu'on vienne parler corruption on
est ravi de le faire essayer de
sensibiliser un peu les futurs électeurs
citoyens élisent van beneden merci merci
avant
[Musique]
e